Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 132. Hallo, ich bin Tim Pritlove, ihr wisst es. Und ich bin immer noch in Wien auf Podcastreise und habe jetzt zum zweiten Mal hier mein Equipment aufgebaut. Und ja, ich möchte dieses Thema heute mal auf was völlig anderes lenken. Hier soll es ja immer um Technologie gehen und aber auch um die Gesellschaft und um die Kultur. Und ich denke, heute kriegen wir das mal alles auf einen Tisch zusammen. Denn ich bin hier selbst zu Gast bei Hans, hallo Hans, Hans Bernhard und bei Liz. Wie nennt man dich eigentlich ganz? Nennt man dich Lizvlx?
Richtig ausgesprochen, so wie man schreibt.
Lizvlx, ja, ist ganz einfach und naheliegend. Richtig schön, hast du den Namen schon immer?
Den habe ich mir genommen, weil ich meinen Namen ganz normal geschrieben habe und die Leute haben ihn immer falsch ausgesprochen. Deshalb habe ich mir was gewählt, was man eh gar nicht aussprechen kann.
Wie praktisch. Aber damit liegst du ja im Prinzip schon voll im Internet-Trend mit so einem coolen Nick.
Ja, das war allerdings noch vor dem Internet.
Ja, einen coolen Nick zu haben schon vor dem Internet ist sehr hilfreich, dann hat man immer noch alle Logins frei. Richtig. Aber du, Hans, bist einfach nur Hans. Richtig. Dich hat es nie gedrängt zu einem Nick.
Also, Hans ist... Also, mein Nickname ist Lucius, aber Hans ist mein Name.
Aber als Lucius trittst du doch eigentlich gar nicht auf, oder?
Naja, manchmal schon. Ich meine, wir haben ja... Was haben wir? Wir haben sicher schon 20, 30 verschiedene Aliases in den letzten zehn Jahren mit Übermorgen irgendwie durch, in den verschiedenen Projekten und so. Aber Hans, nein, Hans ist eigentlich, Hans Bernhard ist ja eigentlich der Name meines Großvaters.
Ach.
Genau.
Und den fandest du dann ganz praktisch?
Nein, das war eigentlich ein Zufall.
Inwiefern war das ein Zufall?
Nein, ich habe halt einen Namen gesucht, der irgendwie so nazimäßig, international funktioniert. Also entweder Fritz oder, ja, dass die Amerikaner irgendwie auch checken. Weil Luzios ist so ein bisschen, was weiß ich, schöner Name, aber funktioniert nicht. Und eben, kann niemand da sprechen, bin ich so wie die Lizvlx. Dieses Bedürfnis nicht. Ich mag es, wenn die Leute sagen Hans, Hans, Hans, 100 Mal. Und das hat gut funktioniert eigentlich. Und dann erst im Nachhinein habe ich gemerkt, dass mein leider viel zu früh verstorbener Großvater, den ich nie kennengelernt habe, die Liz schaut mich jetzt an, dass der ja so geheißen hat. Und das ist eigentlich perfekt.
Man darf ihm einfach nicht alles glauben, was er erzählt.
Nein, nein, das würde ich auch niemals tun. Ja, man sieht schon, ihr habt auf jeden Fall auch Streit und Auseinandersetzung im Inneren. Das ist gut, denn ihr seid ja als Künstler bekannt und da erwartet man sich natürlich auch immer ein gewisses Maß an Streitkultur. Bekannt seid ihr unter dem Namen Ubermorgen oder auch ubermorgen.com. Ich weiß nicht, das gehört dazu, oder?
Wir haben es dabei gelassen, auch nach dem totalen Super-Crash der Mega-Bubble. Weil im Endeffekt ist es ja praktisch.
Aber bewusst ohne Ü. Weil?
Naja, umso eben, dieser Teil der narzisstischen deutschen Kultur, der sich positiv in der englischen Sprache niedergelassen hat, ist ja irgendwie ästhetisch doch sehr interessant.
Du meinst dieses Uber?
Ja, genau. Weil das wird ja im amerikanischen Englisch, also auch im englischen Englisch, aber primär in Amerika auch intensiv verwendet.
Unter uns im Prinzip als vorgenommener Gegentrend zum Bruno, der sich ja dann wieder mit Ü schreitet.
Man muss schon vorausdenken, sonst verdient man kein Geld.
Ja, vorausdenken. Und trotzdem liegt der Name so ein bisschen in die Zukunft mit Übermorgen.
Ja, das ist so die gern gewählte, aber freiwillige Arroganz, die man an den Tag legen muss und möchte als Künstler, denke ich, auf der einen Seite. Und auf der anderen Seite, real gesehen ist es ja so, dass man ständig damit konfrontiert ist, wenn man so Sachen macht wie wir, dass wenn man da mit der Presse und Öffentlichkeit, aber auch mit der Kunst, also jetzt nicht mit Medienkunst und Neumedienkunst, aber mit der Kunst per se zu tun hat, dass man ständig alles erklären muss, weil ja niemand einen Plan hat. Ja, ich glaube, ich muss sagen ja. Ich kenne unterschiedliche Werdegänge, aber jetzt von mir sprechend ja.
Wie hat sich das geäußert?
Ja, dass man als Kind einfach nur am Zeichnen ist und dass man auf der anderen Seite... Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich nur erinnern, wie ich in die Schule gekommen bin, dass es so ist, dass nicht alle anderen Kinder eh das Wissen oder das denkende Wissen haben, das ich habe. Ich dachte, wir sind mehr Borg. Und dann bin ich draufgekommen, wir sind überhaupt nicht Borg. Das waren schrecklich schlimme Einschnitte in meinem Leben. Ich dachte, oh mein Gott, bin ich alleine.
Du warst auf einmal bei den Rebellen sozusagen.
Nein, ich war kein Rebell.
Sondern du warst Luke Skywalker allein auf Tatooine und wusste gar nicht, dass du das warst.
Ich war ein wunderbarer Clown und hatte sehr viel Spass in der Schule. Und er war der volle Schulloser.
Ich war auch Clown, aber ich war auch Clown.
Aber du warst ein Loser und ich nicht.
Aber ich war Clown so aggressiv.
Er glaubte immer, ich war ein Streber. Er war einfach ein Loser. Und alle Loser sagen zu den anderen, dass ich Streber ist.
Mein Vater hat mich, als ich so sieben, acht Jahre alt war, immer in die Kunsthalle mitgenommen, in Basel, und hat mich stehen lassen in irgendwelchen Boys-Installationen drin. Und hat sich halt irgendwas angeschaut. Und ich hab dann... Das war eigentlich der Moment, wo ich gemerkt habe, das ist schon geil, die Kunst. Ich hab das dann wieder verloren. Aber dort war das geil, weil ich mir dachte, bist du deppert. Ich meine, die paar Häuser von einem Typen, der singt eine Schasse, was ist das, Filz und Kupfer und irgendein Mensch kommt da raus. Der kommt da nicht mal selber raus, was er macht. Ich bin aber so drin gestanden und hab mir halt dem hingegeben. Das war schon geil. Weil ich dann gemerkt hab, okay, es gibt Leute, sogar nachdem er tot ist, es gibt Leute, die noch dem huldigen, das anschauen und so. Und ich glaub, dort hab ich gesagt, dann klar, durchs Tun, Teenager, machst halt irgendwie so Zeugs. Aber dann später, in dem Moment, wo es dann mit dem Drogen und der Technologie losgegangen ist, da hat mich dann die Kunst nicht mehr interessiert. Weil das war dann irgendwie abgelöst. Da ging es dann plötzlich um das Experiment und zu sagen, okay, jetzt gehen wir über die Grenzen hinweg und ich erforsche irgendwelche Sphären, die vielleicht noch nie jemand gesehen hat. Und habe dann immer gewusst, okay, aber ich muss zurückkommen. Das war immer wichtig. Also einerseits die Kontrolle zu behalten, nicht völlig kontrolllos zu werden, weil das wäre Absturz und vielleicht Tod oder so. Immer wieder zurückzukommen und dort auch von der Mission zu erzählen. Das war am Anfang vom Internet total wichtig, weil die Leute ja gar nicht gewusst haben. Das war 1994. Also Anfang vom Internet, Anfang vom Web.
Wo das Internet der Öffentlichkeit bekannt wurde.
Genau, ja. Also 1996 war das der Boom. Und 1994 haben wir halt irgendwie experimentiert. Die haben das alle nicht gekannt. Das muss man denen irgendwie erklären, was das ist. Und wir haben uns sogar kennengelernt. Als ich Internetanschlüsse verkauft habe für den ersten oder zweiten österreichischen Provider an einer Computermesse.
Wie romantisch.
Eigentlich haben wir uns direkt davor schon woanders kennengelernt gehabt. Das war während dem Filmdreh, wo es so SM-Technomäßig war. Das war auch sehr romantisch sozusagen.
Ich bin kopfübergehangen und wurde von einer supergeilen Frau ausgepeitscht.
Das war deine Traumvorstellung, bist du da gehangen und hast so getan, es würde dir eh nicht so weh tun.
Ja, aber ich war total knackig mit Lederhosen, nacktem Oberkörper und damals war ich noch nicht so fett, wie das sieht man zwar jetzt, die am Radio nicht, am Podcast.
Doch, die sehen das, ich sagte das, die sehen das. Die googeln kurz und sehen ein aktuelles Bild von dir, die Schweine.
Ja, da war ich echt knackig und frisch und die Liz war irgendwie liert mit dem Kameramann, aber von der Liz habe ich nur die Titten gesehen, an dem Abend.
Und da war es um dich geschehen?
Nein, nein, ich habe nur die Titten gesehen. Sie sahen ein Camouflage-T-Shirt mit so Möbsen drin. Aber ich habe mich für eine andere Frau interessiert damals. Und erst beim Internet-Zugängeverkaufen ist es dann losgegangen.
Und dann seid ihr sozusagen zusammengekommen und habt dann auch gleich gemeinsam geschafft?
Nein, weil ich habe eben was Sinnvolles, was Richtiges studiert, also Handelswissenschaft. Er hat ja nur Kunst studiert, weil er ja keine Matura, keine Abitur hat. Und jetzt geht es, glaube ich, eh nicht mehr, aber da gab es in Österreich noch die Möglichkeit, dass man ohne Abi Kunst studiert. Er ist ja aus einer intellektuellen Familie, es musste natürlich schon schauen, dass er zumindest ein Magister, der backt.
Herausragende künstlerische Fähigkeit.
Genau, kann viel saufen.
Nein, das war die Hintertür ins Studium.
Jedenfalls, ich habe noch richtig studiert mit Zeitaufwand und so weiter, auch mit Gehirn. Und war dann auch wirklich beschäftigt. Du hast damals E-Talk gemacht. Wir waren da irgendwie einig, wie lange waren wir? Vier Jahre waren wir einfach privat liiert. Und dann haben wir zum Zusammenarbeiten angefangen. Auch wegen dem Dortkommando.
Ich war ja in Amerika.
Ich korrigiere mich, wir waren ein Jahr getrennt. Ich habe das irgendwie nicht so mitbekommen.
Du warst in Amerika, aber wir waren nicht getrennt.
Natürlich, körperlich waren wir getrennt.
Aber ihr hattet das Internet. Das hat euch verbunden. Du hast es ihr verkauft, und ihr habt beide daran teilgenommen.
Nein, sie hat es mir nicht verkauft. Das ist ja das Geile. Das Geile ist ja, dass 1994 ich mit ihr das Internet-Zeugs begonnen habe zu machen. Und sie hat aber zu genauer gleichen Zeit in der Wirtschaftsuni auch mit dem Internet-Zeugs angefangen. Und so war die Basis total gegeben, auch für die spätere Zusammenarbeit. Weil wir genau den gleichen Background gehabt haben von der technischen Entwicklung und auch vom Lifestyle. Techno, Drogen, Internet, das war so die Kombi irgendwie.
Na gut, ihr seid ja dann sozusagen ein Teil einer doch existenten, aber doch sehr überschaubaren Künstlergemeinde gewesen, die sich schon recht früh dem Netz zugeneigt hat, kann man so sagen. Einzeln überschaue ich das jetzt auch nicht, wer damals schon alles so die Aktivisten waren. Aber recht früh waren ja schon so Begriffe wie Net Art vielen da immer. Ich konnte da ehrlich gesagt persönlich immer herzlich wenig mit anfangen, aber es war auf jeden Fall offensichtlich, dass es da so eine Gruppe von Leuten gab, die schon auf so eine ganz besondere Art und Weise vom Internet entflammt war. Was hat es euch da gegeben?
Ich fand das super praktisch. Ich habe ja auch Kunst studiert, und habe eben dann wirklich aufgehört, weil es mir zu langweilig war. Und habe auf der einen Seite mich dann mit dem Kontakt mit dem Netz gekommen, weil ich mir gedacht habe, okay, das ist mal sinnvoll, du kannst aufhören, ich meine Bilder kannst du immer noch malen, oder so Zeug, wenn du 80 bist. Aber das kannst du jetzt machen, da macht es Sinn. Und ich habe ja früher schon programmiert, wie ich noch ein Teenie war, halt auf dem C64 und so weiter. Und in dem Sinne war es auch interessant, ich war dann Computertutor auf der WU, der Wirtschaftszone in Wien, ja, Entschuldigung. Richtig, genau. Weil ich mich hier todeln von E-Toy, das ist schreckliche Künstler, der E-Toy, da irgendwie so E-Mails rüber schicken, irgendwie mit ASCII-Pistolen drin, habe ich dann wieder meinen Tutorjob verloren, weil ich damals auch E-Toy-Adresse hatte, E-Mail-Adresse und so. Niemand hat irgendetwas verstanden davon, aber es war einfach total interessant eben, wie das ganze HTML entstanden ist. Erst eben, dann kommt ein neuer Tag raus und dann sind alle nur noch ein paar Frames ab, oder? Und es macht es halt schon einiges interessanter, damit zu experimentieren. Weil du halt wirklich experimentieren kannst und nicht schon alles gegebene entweder wiederholst oder nicht wiederholst, was jetzt in der normalen Fine-Art halt eher der Fall ist.
Ich fahre immer noch mit so einer Langsamkeit, die man heute gar nicht mehr feststellen kann. Also wenn du sagst, so jeden Tag ein neues Tag.
Ja, und das andere natürlich, was ich immer super geil gefunden habe, ist das, was ja schon auch noch jetzt irgendwie eine Rolle spielt, halt anders, nicht so in Bezug auf Bandwidth eher, sondern also nicht mehr, aber damals halt, dass wir wirklich schauen müssen, dass das Zeug halt schön klein ist. Und ich finde das Arbeiten unter Einschränkung immer interessanter, als wenn alles möglich ist. Weil das hat dann so eben eine eher analytische, sehr starke analytische Komponente dabei. Und das gibt einfach, weiß ich nicht, interessantere Resultate.
Also der Netzraum war sozusagen auch so ein bisschen künstlerischer als Käse, ja?
Na ja, es ging um die Limitation. Weil in unserem Umfeld, also in meinem Umfeld, in der Kunstuni haben die Leute solche Graphics-Maschinen um 500.000 Euro und dann möglichst potent irgendwie die Animationen rausgerechnet über drei Wochen hinweg. Und wir haben halt gesagt, okay, wir haben gesagt, 20 Kb. Mit 20 Kb müssen wir die ganze Story erzählen, weil das geht sonst viel zu lang. Weil das war auf diesen geschlissen Modems.
Mit 20 Kb, was?
Mit 20 Kb haben wir, da haben wir Audio, da haben wir Grafik und Text. Also eine HTML-Seite. Eine HTML-Seite, 20 Kb. Das ist ja schon viel. Das war irgendwie sozusagen die Limitation.
So ein bisschen wie die Demoszene mit ihrem 64K-Dokma.
Ja, aber das war ja Notwendigkeit, oder?
Ja, aber es war eine technische und quasi auch in Bezug auf den Konsumenten gedachte Notwendigkeit. Aber das andere, was du gefragt hast, im 94, 95, 96 hat sich diese Net Art, ich mag den Begriff eigentlich, weil für mich symbolisiert eine Gruppe von hochinteressanten Künstlern, die in der Zeit ganz individuelles Zeug mit dem selben Medium gemacht haben. Und jeder von denen gehört zu unserem weiteren Umfeld. Nein, es ist wie ein Stamm, ein Tribe. Und das ist aber wirklich mein Tribe. Weil heute noch, das sind die engsten Verbindungen, die ich hauptkünstlerisch. Nicht jetzt unbedingt im Arbeiten, aber ich weiss immer, wer, wo, wie, mit wem war es und so. Das ist auch das, wo ich mich wirklich wohlfühle.
Und das ohne Facebook?
Ohne Facebook. Ja, oder jetzt auch mit, aber das ist wurscht, das ist nicht notwendig. Das heisst, diese Leute verfolgen mich jetzt seit fünfzehn oder so. Und man trifft sich, das hat dort angefangen. Dieser Stamm zieht halt um die Welt, und sie sind von überall. Und man trifft sich dort, man trifft sich in Linz und Ars Electronica, man trifft sich an der Konferenz bei der Ausstellung, bei dem Symposium und so.
Ja, wir sind ja auch schon ein paar Mal über den Weg gelaufen.
Richtig, ja.
Hier und da. Auch wenn ich da nicht so täglich rumschwöre. Ihr seid ja dann gleich mit diesem Übermorgen gestartet. Also ist das sozusagen euer gemeinsames Ding gewesen, oder habt ihr da erstmal jeder seine eigenen Wege verfolgt?
Es hat jeder seine eigenen Wege. Ich habe damals ein Projekt, nachdem das User Unfriendly hieß, einfach nur auf IP-Adresse lief, weil es ja noch irrsinniger war, diese depperten Dummerins wegzuprogrammieren, aus dem Zeugs, gemacht. Und dann kam der Dotcom-Boom. Und dann haben wir gemeinsam kommerziell gearbeitet, weil wir gesagt haben, da kann man ein bisschen cashen. Und ich hatte auch keine Lust, in einer blöden Agentur zu arbeiten. Also habe ich gemacht, ein halbes Jahr, und das war so was von... Nein, das war einfach die, das ist so dumm, das Umfeld. Und dann ging das ganz gut. Wir haben nämlich relativ viel so Beratungszeugs gemacht. Also, das war nicht nur okay für uns und für die Kunden auch, sondern wir mussten eigentlich relativ wenig dafür tun. Und nicht, weil wir die Leute verarscht haben, sondern weil wir einfach so einen Vorsprung hatten. Und das war echt praktisch. Und dann haben wir aber gesehen, dass es eigentlich ganz gut läuft in der Zusammenarbeit zwischen uns. Und da wir natürlich vorher schon viel miteinander Austausch hatten, künstlerischen, also sich gegenseitig feedbacken, einfach so, meine ich, haben wir dann gesagt, ja, dann machen wir halt mal gemeinsam. Und dann haben wir ein kleines Testprojekt gemacht. Ars Electronica geht jetzt nach Linux, wegen der Intervention von Microsoft.
Ja, das war ein geiler Testprojekt. Da haben wir Ars Electronica für die Leute, die es nicht kennen, der wichtigste internationale Preis für Computer-Animation. Medienkunst zum Beispiel. Dieses Jahr, das war 1999 wahrscheinlich, ist der Preis an Linux gegangen. Und zwar eigentlich an Linus Torwalds. Und es gab kein Feedback in der Szene. Es war so... Ja, es gab einfach keine Reaktion. Und wir haben gefunden, das ist total komisch, weil es ist... Aus dem Kunstverständnis her ist es mir nicht nachvollziehbar, wieso ein Open Source Software-Projekt den Kunstpreis kriegt. Kann ich aber akzeptieren, wenn man es mir argumentiert. Wurde aber nicht argumentiert. Und das Zweite ist, wieso an Linus Torwalds? Es war die... Was weiß ich?
Auslösende Figur.
Auslösend, federführend oder was auch immer, aber es sind Tausende von Leuten. Und du kannst... Dann gibt es das System, aber nicht an die Person. Das Geilste war dann, seine Schwester hat aus dem Preis entgegen genommen. Was echt so... Okay, jetzt ist es echt... Jetzt habt ihr die Leinen überschritten. Aber was wir gemacht haben, ist dann, weil es keine Reaktion gab, haben wir gesagt, wir schauen mal, ob es Reaktionen gibt. Und wir haben im Namen der Jury, aber nur von vier, von fünf Jurymitgliedern, vier haben unterschrieben, eine Mail rausgeschickt an 100.000 Leute aus der Szene, Journalisten und so weiter, wo drin gestanden ist, dass sie sehr wahrscheinlich, also dass das Ganze manipuliert war. Und zwar von den grossen Computer-Corporations, die die Ars Electronica sponsor, um Linux als Test in der Kunstszene zu fahren, um sie später auf ihren HP-Kisten und Tell-Kisten zu installieren. Und hat sich ja nachher als Richtiger herausgestellt, quasi unsere Vision, dass sie das machen wollen. War natürlich aber ein Fake. Und wir haben das halt so beschrieben, dass dann der amerikanische Jury-Mitglied, der hat dann irgendwie plötzlich seine Meinung geändert und vorher waren diese ganzen Corporate-Fuzzies irgendwie rum und haben... Und so. Also es war so eine Lusche-Geschichte. Und es hat eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe. Die Reaktion waren Dementis von der Ars Electronica, überflutete E-Mail-Accounts, Dutzende oder Hunderte von Artikeln, die sich aufgebaut haben und dann sofort wieder dementiert wurden. Und das Geilste war, dass sich dann, und das haben sie mir glaube ich nie verziehen, dann neben dem Gerfried Stocker und der Christine Schöff die zwei Köpfe quasi der Ars Electronica oder die zwei von dreien, am nächsten Montag des Festwurfs bin ich halt zwischen sie hingestanden und habe gesagt, und? Alles in Ordnung? Und sie haben so mit säuerlicher Mine irgendwie und sie haben gesagt, also alles okay. Ich weiss aber nicht, ob sie gewusst haben, dass wir dahinter gesteckt sind. Also ich glaube sie haben gemeint, dass AIDA irgendwie dahinter und so. Es war dann ein Kauf. Böses Blut.
Aber auf jeden Fall, es war halt auch so ein Testprojekt, das wir gleich so gemacht haben in unserer Methode, dass man jetzt nicht auf gut Glück irgendwas rausschickt, sondern eben auch sehr analytisch sich überlegt, was muss man mit was kombinieren. Nicht um Reaktion A oder B zu bekommen, sondern um möglichst viel Reaktion zu bekommen. Und dass man das eben nicht nur an die Kunstszene schickt, sondern auch an die Techno-Szene, an die Kultur-Szene. Und eben damit man verschiedene Targets-Groups irgendwie erreicht und das auch in Text zu schreiben, dass jeder was drin entfindet, was er versteht.
Klar, ich meine, es war aufs Airstart oder aufs Linux-Detail und so.
Es war so eine Art Bombentest.
Und ich meine, wir haben drei oder vier Wochen, man muss sich mal vorstellen, an einer beschissenen E-Mail drei oder vier Wochen arbeiten. Das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Das fand auch deutlich nach der Ars Electronica statt.
Nein, nein, nein.
Am Wochenende vor der Ars ist die Bombe rausgegangen.
Richtig schön getimt. Ja, wir haben es genauso. Wir teilen das meistens so, dass wir das am Sonntag rausschicken, wenn es geht, damit es am Montag, wenn die Leute ins Büro kommen, schön am Tisch schon liegt. Und abhängig davon auch zeitsohne und technisch natürlich, dass man manchmal den Vorsprung gibt und so weiter, dass es überlegt jeweils. Und es war damals auch so, dass, glaube ich, die Ars am Montag dann die erste große Pressekonferenz hatte, wo sie ihre ganzen Preisträger vorgestellt haben und so weiter. Und dann sind halt die ganzen Schuhe gekommen und haben nur deswegen dieser blöden E-Mail gefragt. Und das haben sie halt echt ziemlich mühsam gefunden. So Details überlegt man sich natürlich nicht. Aber das hat einfach gut funktioniert, das haben wir gemerkt.
Ja, und es war nicht eine Provokation oder Destruktive. Das war nicht die Motivation, sondern die Motivation war wirklich, was ist los? Kein Statement, keine Reaktion, niemand sagt was. Irgendwas ist faul in dem ganzen Scheiss. Ja, es war irgendwie was faul.
Dann habt ihr einfach so eine kleine Verschwörungstheorie als Testballon gefahren und gesehen. Und dabei sozusagen auch gelernt, wie man unter Ausnutzung des Netzes Medium ist und Medium spielt und mit den Medien spielt. Media-Hacking nennt ihr das, glaube ich, auch. Da kommt es natürlich auch so ein bisschen rein hier, in unseren Chaos-Computer-Club-Kontext. Was gibt euch der Begriff Hacker und Hacking? Ich glaube, Lizvlx, wir haben uns das erste Mal sogar auf einem Camp gesehen, glaube ich. Auf einem Chaos-Communication-Camp.
CCC 2000, also bei. Der Convention.
Beim Kongress, Entschuldigung.
Da habe ich einen Vortrag über VodAuction gemacht.
Da haben wir uns wahrscheinlich das erste Mal gesehen. Ich kann mich nur als Camp erinnern. Aber ihr habt ja sozusagen schon früh Kontakt gehabt.
Was ist so euer Verhältnis zur Hacker-Szene? Ich hatte früher schon Kontakt natürlich, dadurch, dass ich Computer-Tutor war. Und da waren natürlich schon diverse andere Leute, die Sysadmins waren auf der Wirtschaftszone, so eine große Uni mit ca. 30.000 Studenten, die sehr früh schon für alle E-Mails eingeführt hat, zum Anmelden für Lehrveranstaltungen und so weiter. Das heißt, die Sysadmins von der Uni waren a. mächtige Leute und b. Ich weiß, dass ich prinzipiell auf... Mir wurde das Hacken schon oft vorgeworfen von der Uni damals, eben, dass ich fremde Server infiltriere und so weiter. Da haben wir gedacht, ich tue ja gar nichts. Aber man traut es mir sozusagen zu, was immer gut ist, das ist klar. Wir hatten es öfter mal mit Hackern zu tun, auch bei dem VoteAction-Projekt. Da hat uns mal ein deutsch sprechender Typ aus Texas unsere ganzen Maschinen zusammengefahren. Ich nehme an, das war halt jemand von einer OGA, das heißt Other Government Agency. Aber es ist für mich natürlich ein positiver Begriff. Das ist halt immer die prinzipielle Frage. Oder soll man das System attackieren, weil man im Endeffekt dem System dabei nur hilft, dass es besser wird? Darauf gibt es ja nicht wirklich eine Antwort. Also besser tut man es auf jeden Absicht, und nicht blau-eigig, sagen wir mal so.
Und seht ihr da noch eine andere Verbindung zwischen der Hackerszene und dieser Net-Art- oder Kunstszene im Allgemeinen? Gibt es da Verbindungen?
Wir haben den Begriff Media Hacking für uns entwickelt, um uns dort abzugrenzen und zu definieren, was wir machen. Media Hacking heisst für uns das Eindringen in Massenmediale, Kanäle mit Low-Tech. Low-Tech heisst für uns E-Mail, Web, SMS, Phones, irgendwelches Flyers, was auch immer. Und eine Story. Die Story ist der Aufhänger. Die Story ist quasi der Virus, der sich verbreitet und repliziert und in den Massenmedien dann von oben runtergeschüttet wird. Und zum Teil geht er natürlich auch von unten über die Blogsphere oder E-Mails, geht darauf in die Massenmedien.
Ihr habt es ja schon erwähnt, eine der, ich denke vielleicht sogar die auffälligste Aktion, die ihr gemacht habt, ist eben das Vote-Auction-Projekt.
Wann war das?
2000.
Das war Bush gegen Gore, wo damals wir erinnern uns, Gore gewonnen hat und dann Bush die Krone gekriegt hat. Das war so ein Projekt, das sich so ergeben hat. Das ist auch eine Arbeitstechnik, die wir immer wieder verwenden, dass wir jetzt nicht absichtlich ein Ziel verfolgen, sondern Sachen entstehen lassen. Da war ein amerikanischer Student, der eine Diplomarbeit gemacht hat, einfach in einer Kunstuni. Allerdings ist es so eine komische Militärkunstuni, speziell. Und der hat eben dafür eine Website gemacht, wo man Stimmen verkaufen und kaufen konnte. Es ist einfach so eine Auktionsplattform. Also jetzt ganz Low-Tech, nichts programmiertes, sondern einfach nur so eine Website. Er hat natürlich relativ große Probleme für das, was er sich erwartet hat, bekommen mit den amerikanischen Behörden und wollte das Ding sofort loswerden. Und da gab es die Artmark, die heißen jetzt Yes Man, die er kannte, weil ein Typ von ihm war Professor von ihm, und die mit ihm waren wir auch befreundet. Und da kam so ein Kontakt zustande, wir haben dem dann das Projekt abgekauft.
Also so richtig mit Geld?
Ja, den klassischen, symbolischen Euro slash Dollar. Machen doch die Großen gehört.
Aber was war seine Motivation jetzt überhaupt, diese Webseite?
Seine Motivation war eine politische. Also er wollte die Korruption des Wahlverfahrens, vor allem die Wahlkampagnenfinanzierung, wollte er quasi an den Pranger stellen oder hängen. Und war dann aber sofort vom FBI untertrogen, New York City Election Committee und so weiter, und hat uns das dann verkauft. Wir haben das Projekt nicht als politisches Projekt gesehen. Wir haben gesagt, Media-Hacking, wir haben gesagt, perfekt. Die Massmedien, das war schon vorbereitet. Da gab es schon eine Story of Wired und so. Das war klar, okay, das fliegt jetzt von weg.
Das war noch vor der Wahl?
Nein, das war vier Monate vor der Wahl.
Das war mitten im Sommer vor der Wahl.
Das war vier Monate vor der Wahl. Und dann ist das Ding geflogen. Wir haben dann die Webseite noch überarbeitet irgendwie, weil die hat so scheiße aufgesagt. Wir haben geschaut, dass sie trotzdem noch scheiße ausschaut, weil das war irgendwie so...
Authentisch. Authentische Scheiße.
Aber es war irgendwie... Und dann ist das Ding geflogen. Und ich meine, wir haben dann...
Unter welcher Domain war das erreichbar?
Das war zuerst... Ja, das ist eine... Zuerst war das... Das war dann unter verschiedenen Domains erreichbar.
Da haben wir eine neue Methode. Der Zeitplan ist bei uns im Projekt, wie vorhin schon erwähnt, relativ wichtig. Wir hatten dann noch einen Zeitplan, wie man immer von welcher Domain auf die nächste wechselt. Damit immer, wenn man abgedreht wird, man wieder sofort einen Press-Release rauslassen kann, dass man wieder ein neuer Domain hat, was automatisch wieder eine Story publiziert. Weil die Leute ja froh sind, wenn sie was haben, damit sie darüber sprechen können. Nein, das lief unter vote auction durchgeschrieben.com, dann vote bindestich auction.com, dann vote bindestich auction.net.
Da ist es jetzt auch erreichbar.
Und da ist es noch immer erreichbar. Dazwischen nur noch auf der IP. Und am Schluss haben wir auch diversen, ca. 50 andere Websites auf uns weitergeleitet.
Zum Beispiel auch hell.com. hell.com hat die ganze Website runtergenommen und hat alles, allen Traffic, auf uns weitergeleitet, ein paar Tage lang.
Und warum müsstet ihr immer wieder fliehen? Also, wenn euch die Domänen entzogen?
Also, juristisch gesehen ist das ja so ein Fall, der in den Lehrbüchern jetzt auch drin ist.
Da denken wir doch, da sind wir wieder... Der hat das bei der ICAN mehrere Male, haben die das dort im Board irgendwie besprochen, den Fall, weil das eben so, ja, ich hab dich unterbrochen.
Na, es war einfach so, dass die erste Domäne war ja normal in Amerika registriert, ist klar, weil das ja der Arme-Student, der James Baumgarton dort irgendwie mal gemacht hat. Und normaler Usus, wie das dann halt ist, wenn es dann halt irgendeine Anklage gibt, dass dann der Provider sagt, okay, ich nehme es runter, wenn ihr mir nicht irgendwie einfach ein Down-Payment macht für etwaige Rechtskosten. Das Down-Payment wäre gewesen, eben kam mir noch ein Telefonat da rinnen, 100.000 Dollar, und hat gerade mein Geldbörsel vergessen gehabt, also das ging jetzt nicht. Und dann war natürlich klar, dann schaltet er es natürlich ab und dann gibt es immer noch ein paar Tage Zeit, oder? Und dann gehst du halt auf die nächste Domain. Die haben ja dann bald mit Joker schon registriert und was ja dann eigentlich so in Wirklichkeit wieder in der Schweiz ist, ist alles irgendwie relativ kompliziert. Aber halt eher in der EU, dann ist komplizierter, die Sachen abzudrehen. Trotzdem ist das ja im Endeffekt, es waren ja Top-Level-Domains, die im Endeffekt natürlich in Amerika ein- und ausgeschaltet werden, aus der Datenbank. Und so haben die das einfach auch gemacht, die haben einfach illegal, auf dem Pseudo-Rechtsweg, nennen wir es so, auf dem Pseudo-Rechtsweg, die Domains immer wieder abschalten lassen.
Es gab schon dann die.
Die, das war das Beste, da habe ich telefoniert, einmal habe ich mit den Leuten gesagt, was da jetzt los ist, halt auf Englisch, es gab was da jetzt irgendwie los ist, wo das jetzt wieder hin ist und so weiter. Da haben sie gesagt, wer hat das gemacht? Da haben sie gesagt, it's the Registry. Da sage ich, welche Registry jetzt? Ich meine, welcher denn? Und sie haben gesagt, the Registry, the file. Und dann abgedreht, das geht natürlich leicht. Ich meine, das ist dann irgendwie eben, das waren FBI, CIA und NSA, die das gemacht haben. Das ist jetzt ohne Verschwörung.
Plus, das ist die eine Seite, und die andere Seite waren 13, ein zweiliger Verfügung von 13 verschiedenen Bundesstaaten. Und Janet Reno, die Federal Attorney, hat auch das Ganze untersucht. Der Druck war enorm hoch. Und wir haben jeden Tag 3, 4, 5 FedEx-UPS-Lieferungen gekriegt mit solchen 3, 4 Zentimeter dicken Backen von juristischen Urteilen, die gesagt haben, entweder ihr stoppt jetzt mit Votoxen oder ihr müsst jeden Tag 10'000 Dollar zahlen. Und zum Teil haben sie eben die Domäne angegriffen. Das Problem war, die amerikanische Domäne, ja klar, die war weg innerhalb von 5 Minuten. Aber die Domäne, die zum Beispiel von Joker, die die Liste an bei Joker in Deutschland gekauft hat, war aber ein Zwischenhändler, das habe ich nie durchschaut, Cornick in Genf. Und Cornick hat eine E-Mail von irgendeinem Gericht gekriegt in den USA und dreht ab. Und ich rufe die an und sage, was ist los? Und dann sagen sie, das ist illegal, was ihr macht. Ich habe gesagt, nein, ist es nicht. In Europa ist es nicht illegal, amerikanische Wahlstimmen zu kaufen und zu verkaufen. Hör auf zu träumen, Vollidiot. Das ist nur in den USA illegal. Ja, aber unsere Mitarbeiter in den USA, das ist illegal. Und wir lassen das so. Ich habe gesagt, das ist illegal, was ihr macht. Aber du hast es nicht diskutieren können, oder? Und so hat sich der Druck, der juristische Druck, hat sich enorm aufgebaut. Und eben dadurch, durch die Dienste, diese Agencies, war uns auch klar, der Hack, der passiert ist. Und was sehe ich, irgendwelche NSAs oder CIAs, die gehen natürlich rein bei dir. Die spazieren da rein in den Server und holen sich das Zeug und dann gehen sie wieder. Und wir mussten ja auch die Leute, die sich angemeldet haben, für den Wahlstimmenverkauf.
Das FBI aber nicht, bitte.
Die mussten wir schützen. Weil die haben sich wirklich strafbar gemacht. Und wenn die in den USA leben, dann können die auch in den Knast dafür.
Hat denn die Seite wirklich funktioniert?
Nein! Entschuldige, du hast ja keine Ahnung von Programmieren. Bitte sag nicht Ja oder Nein auf solche Fragen.
Aber wenn du auf eBay gegangen wärst und geschaut hättest, wie eine Aktion ausschaut, hättest du sehen können, das ist far beyond.
Das waren so absurde Sachen. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass wir da eben schon so eine Pseudo-Life-Feedback-Situation die ganze Zeit hatten von Medien und Gerichten und Gerichtstokumenten. Das heisst, ich ändere irgendwas auf der Website und dann sehe ich, dann kriege ich wieder ein neues Gerichtstokument, da steht dann drinnen, dass dieser Experte der Meinung ist, es ist keine richtige Aktionsplattform, weil ja auch kein Warenkorb darauf zu sehen sei. Darauf denken wir, na gut, dann machen wir ein paar Pixel Warenkorb dazu, ist ja kein Problem. Und dann gehen wir halt die paar Pixel rauf, denkst du so, was ist jetzt mit deiner Argumentation? Und da muss man forschen, das sind Sachen, das ist ja dann ja, da müssen sich dann irgendwie fünf Leute in einem Zimmer versammeln, damit einer, einer ist der Computerexperte, der nächste ist der, weiß ich nicht, Sprachexperte, falls Fremdsprachen auch dabei sind, einer, einer ist der Judge, einer ist der Staatsanwalt und einer ist noch ein Zeuge, dass die alle gleichzeitig da anwesend sind und wirklich das vor sich sehen. Weil die versuchen natürlich eine Beweiswirkung irgendwie zu produzieren, dadurch, dass sie sich irgendwie an die Website anschauen. Und dann sagen sie, ja, sie haben zu dem Zeitpunkt das hier auf der Website gesehen und diesen Screenshot gemacht und dann hier gemeinsam ausgedruckt unterschreiben, jetzt alle drauf. Und du denkst dir, ja super, wenn ich IP-Routing mache, dann kriegt man andere was anderes. Ich meine, das ist ja lächerlich. Es hat ja alles keine Beweiskraft und es ist lustig, wenn man dann so das Schwarz auf Weiß liest, wie sich so Mengen an Leuten zusammentun, um aus dem digitalen Wahn eine reale Beweiskraft herauszukriegen, die nicht gegeben ist. Das ist klar.
Und das Ganze kostet Millionen von Dollar. Das waren 13 DAs und FBI, NSA, CIA, what the fuck. Und die haben Millionen verbraten. Wir haben hier drüben 500 Kilo oder 700 Kilo juristische Dokumente, die wir gekriegt haben. Damit haben wir Skulpturen gemacht. Die sind gross. Die haben wir ausgestellt, in Museen ausgestellt. Nur das Papier. Aber das ist jetzt mal der technische und der juristische Teil. Der mediale Teil war ja dann die ganz andere Geschichte. Da ist es abgegangen wie eine Rakete. Wir haben über drei, vier Monate hinweg 30, 40 Interviews, E-Mail, Telefon, auf den verschiedensten Levels Interviews gemacht und die dann sind international. Das war nicht nur in den USA. Das war auch interessant, weil wir haben dann das gleiche Projekt 2007 kommissioniert, nochmals in der Schweiz gemacht. Und das war ein Sturm im Wasserglas. 24 Stunden und dann war das Thema weg. Aber die amerikanische, weil das so wichtig ist für die ganze Welt, der amerikanische Präsident. Sie haben uns auch immer gefragt, warum mischt ihr, die Journalisten, warum mischt ihr Europäer euch in unser System und Demokratie und so. Dann haben wir gesagt, naja, der amerikanische Präsident ist der Weltpräsident im Endeffekt. Das werdet ihr ja nicht bestreiten. Ihr stellt die uneingeschränkte Führung, den Führungsanspruch, also muss demokratisch. Und Demokratie wollte sie auch. Und das war dann das affirmative Killer-Argument irgendwie. Aber dann ist es abgegangen. Das hat Dimensionen erreicht, die ich noch nie gesehen habe. Und der Höhepunkt-Medial war dann 30 Minuten auf CNN, Primetime, eine Sendung, wo es nur, da waren irgendwie 10 Leute, fünf Juristen und der Typ von der Domainbank, die erste Domain und ein Internet-Rechtsprofessor von Stanford usw. Und ich war am Telefon. Und wir waren in Berlin im Boot Lab. Das war das Interview. Und ich habe es am Communicator gemacht. Und ihr habt es auf dem Stream CNN geschaut. Und es hat so ein Delay drin gehabt. Und ich bin immer wieder rüber und die Liz hat mir gesagt, was ich sagen soll. Und dann habe ich es wieder gesagt. Und dann ist es zehn Sekunden später, ist es aus der Kiste rausgekommen. Das war total geil.
Das heißt, du hast am Telefon jetzt gar nicht der Sendung folgen können, oder?
Nein, das ist nicht gegangen.
Nein, ich habe nur die Sendung gehört im Communicate. Und sie haben sie zehn Sekunden später gehört auf dem Ding.
Deshalb konnte man immer... Es ging sich auf jeden Fall so aus, weil du kannst ja nicht gleichzeitig alle anrufen, was alle sagen, und gleichzeitig brauchst du irgendwie einen Regie sozusagen. Und das ging aber super gut. Ich meine, wir versuchen da Low-Tech-gute Ergebnisse zu fahren. Und es geht dann eben doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich muss mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Ihr habt dieses Projekt übernommen und dachtet euch super. Damit kann man erstmal was thematisieren. Was würdet ihr sagen, war jetzt so die eigentliche Botschaft des Projektes? Da ging es ja nicht darum, man kann im Internet Stimmen kaufen.
Die Botschaft bei unserem Projekt ist eigentlich, wenn immer eine, die heißt, denkt selber darüber nach. Also unsere persönliche Meinung ist eine persönliche Meinung von vielen, die vollkommen irrelevant ist. Und von diesem künstlerischen Genius, der dann irgendwie die tolle Meinung hat, halte ich überhaupt nicht. Und das heißt, in dem Sinn ist natürlich klar, dass man sich jetzt, wir haben ja das ganze Projekt durchgeführt, dass wir gesagt haben, wir sind jetzt keine Künstler, und das hat uns auch abgenommen. Wir haben gesagt, wir sind ein Enterprise, wir sind ein Unternehmen, wir möchten das machen. Und die Leute haben gesagt, wie will man damit Geld verdienen? Wir haben gesagt, da braucht man kein Geld verdienen. Das ist jetzt der Test-Case. Und damit will man kein Geld verdienen. Man will ja nicht mit Prototypen Geld verdienen. Erst wollen wir in die Massenproduktion gehen, wir wollen das jetzt in Amerika testen, wir wollen es dann weltweit machen, und dann, wenn wir Accounting is of Scale machen, dann verdienen wir Geld.
Posteuropäische Geschäftsleute, die den amerikanischen Wahlstimmen-Markt entwickeln wollen. Wir wollen in 20 Jahren Cash machen und nicht jetzt. Wir wissen, dass in 20 Jahren das ein riesiger Markt ist. Und ich bin auch persönlich der Überzeugung, dass es so ist. Und übrigens, es ist gerade jetzt so, es wird jetzt aufgemacht, Supreme Court am 9. September 2009 wird der Supreme Court, das weiss man jetzt schon, der USA entscheiden, dass die amerikanischen Firmen uneingeschränkt Wahlkämpfe finanzieren können. Alles fällt jetzt, die ganzen Pack-Scheisse, das fällt alles. Eigentlich passiert jetzt genau das, was wir vor 10 Jahren gesagt haben, dass es passieren wird.
Aber um die Wahl ging es euch eigentlich gar nicht so sehr, sondern es geht richtig... Sehr gut, aber ich meine, was unten dabei rauskommt, also das ist zumindest das, was ich jetzt da rauslese, ist natürlich auch erstmal eine Kritik am wirtschaftlichen System als solches. Was am Pranger steht, ist dieses, man kann sich aus jeder Scheiße Geld machen. Sogar aus dem demokratischen System, nichts hat mehr eine große Bedeutung. Das ist eigentlich auch egal, wenn ich jetzt da so eine Interpretation erinnere. Bin ich jetzt für eine von tausend Stimmen? Jetzt habe ich wahrscheinlich wieder repräsentiert, was schon 100 Leute gesagt haben, oder bin wir eine ganz neue Facette? Weiß ich nicht. Aber das steckt ja im Prinzip drin, in diesem Ansatz, den ihr fahrt.
Du hast ja schon recht, aber es geht denke ich mir dann darum, wenn du das jetzt auch vergleichst, ich meine, jetzt kann man sogar aus dem Geld machen, ja, aber wenn ich jetzt das Gut stimme, vergleiche ich mit anderen Gütern, wie zum Beispiel Wasser, ist es eigentlich viel absurder, dass man mit Wasser handelt, als dass man mit Wahlstimmen handelt. Und das tut man ja auch.
Aber das Entsetzen wäre jetzt bei Wasser nicht so groß gewesen.
Ja, das ist richtig, ja. Das heißt, es sagt maximal aus, dass viele Leute dumm sind, also nicht per Geburt, sondern ignorant, meine ich damit dumm. Ich bin ja jetzt so ein Wirtschaftsmensch in Sachen Know-how und es erstaunt mich immer wieder, wenn auch jetzt zum Beispiel die Leute Kapitalismus schimpfen, ist groß. Jetzt gerade, wie wir gerade eine schlimme Krise unter uns haben, ich habe gerade Anführungszeichen gemacht in die Luft. Weil ich dann immer sage, das ist aber kein Kapitalismus. Kapitalismus basiert auf anderen Sachen. Wenn wir bei Auction-Kapitalismus, wo du wirklich einen offenen Markt hast, wo alle die gleiche Information haben, gleichzeitig Zugriff, das ist Kapitalismus. Das sind alles total positive Sachen. Ich finde Kapitalismus nicht die Lösung, überhaupt nicht. Oder Kapitalismus findet sich ja selbst nicht als die Lösung. Sagt ja auch nur, ist das ein Weg? Und am Ende des Donners ist das große Licht und dann haben wir etwas anderes. Das wissen ja die Leute nicht. Das wäre sinnvoll, das eigentlich zu wissen, Bescheid darüber zu wissen, über das man eigentlich schimpft. Also das Thema an sich ist, wenn schon Kapitalismus, die Grenzen des Kapitalismus, nennen sie mal so, wie es war ja die Tagline von VodAction, war ja auch Bring capitalism and democracy closer together. Und Guantanamo klingt auch schön als Wort. Und im Endeffekt, thematisch geht es uns um viel abstraktere Sachen sozusagen. Es sind nur symbolhafte Momente. Und wenn man sagt, ok, jetzt ist eine Wahl, jetzt kann man mit den Sachen, kann man jetzt sich eine Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Und nicht nur Aufmerksamkeit bekommen eben für uns, sondern viel mehr für viele. Weil ich weiß ja dann, da sitzen ja nicht nur wir da und überlegen uns was zu dem Thema, sondern sitzen ja Millionen von normalen Usern, sag ich mal, auch rum und denken sich, was erzählen die Vollidioten da auf CNN? Oder denken sich zumindest, sie keine große Chance haben, sich irgendwie zusammenzuschließen. Ich meine, eben zwar 2000, ist jetzt noch einmal anders. Und mir ist es eben schon auch wichtig, dass man dann Sachen aufgreift, die für Leute relevant sind. In dem Sinn ist jetzt unsere Kunst auch eben sehr inspiriert von Pop-Art, im Sinne jetzt Pop-Kultur, Pop-Musik, auch wenn man sagt, man beschäftigt sich auch mit Inhalten, die von Interesse sind in der Grundgesamtheit und muss sich nicht jetzt irgendwie so wie ein Fine-Artist hinstellen und sagen, ich öffne mich persönlich groß der Welt, weil ich so interessant bin. Also wir schauen jetzt eher, dass wir nicht Pop-Art sind, sondern mehr Rock-Art, weil das dann doch ein bisschen interessanter ist. Aber das, denke ich, ist so das Thema dabei. Und wir haben immer gesagt, bei so Sachen wie Vote Action, wir gehen ja rein und haben relativ wenig Ahnung von dem Thema, doch mehr als vielleicht der 0815-Mensch, ist klar. Aber das Know-How, das wir bekommen haben, haben wir doch auch unsere User bekommen, die uns ständig Mails geschickt haben und gesagt haben, ja, aber dort und dort hat der und der den so und so bestochen und dort ist das so gewesen und das Gericht ist so und der Staatsanwalt ist so. Und dann weiß man natürlich immer mehr als alle anderen und wir haben uns eigentlich primär als Spiegel empfunden und nicht als Kreator sozusagen.
Aber die Währung, in der ihr eigentlich dann bezahlt werdet, ist ja eigentlich diese Aufmerksamkeit, die ihr generiert habt.
Ja, da wollte ich jetzt gerade was sagen, weil ich stimme da gar nicht überein mit Liz, also schon, aber das ist halt ihre Motivation oder ihre Angehensweise für solche Projekte. Was mich interessiert, ist, das ist nicht die Bezahlung, ist nicht die Aufmerksamkeit, weil die ist nicht authentisch. Die ist ja nur eben für eine Website, für eine Story.
Vielleicht korrigieren wir nicht so sehr die Aufmerksamkeit für euch als Durchführer, sondern die Aufmerksamkeit, die alle diesem Ereignis widmet.
Ja, nennen wir es aber anders. Nennen wir es einen kommunikativen Wahn, eine massenmediale Hysterie. Und das Geile, und das ist das, was mich interessiert an solchen Projekten, es ist wirklich das Experiment. Da stimme ich dir schon bei. Wir wissen von gar nichts richtig. Es kommt zu uns, wir klauen es, wir kaufen es uns ein. Wir übernehmen es. Wir sind grosskotzig genug, zu sagen, wir machen das irgendwie. Wir haben aber auch Mut und stellen uns hin. Und dann geht es ab, in dem Fall. Und dann ist das wie so ein Sturm. Und du bist wie im Auge des Sturms. Und das war wirklich ein Wahnsinn. Also das mit dieser Osteuropäischen und dann Bulgarien haben wir noch reingenommen wegen der ganzen Techno-Hacker-Kultur usw. Das hat die Leute völlig wahnsinnig gemacht. Und du streust das halt rein. Und es sind so Feedback Loops, die du dann generierst. Also du redest mit einem Journalisten, du erzählst ihm irgendeinen Scheiss, der dir gerade in den Sinn kommt, der streut das weiter, gibts runter in die Pyramide, dann kommt es wieder zurück, die Story, und du spinnst es so Spindoktor-mässig, wie es in der Politik auch gibt. Und dann spinnst du wieder irgendetwas raus mit einem speziellen Drift oder noch einem Zusatz, und dann lebt das wieder weiter. Und das ist das, was mich interessiert. Und das war halt bei Photo-Action das Extremste. Vorher und nachher haben wir das in der Dimension. Ich rechne mit 400 bis 500 Millionen Leuten, die das Projekt in irgendeiner Form mit dem Projekt konfrontiert wurden, medial gesehen.
Eine ähnliche Herangehensweise, ihr habt es ja auch schon erwähnt, haben die Yes Man? Du hast gesagt, die hatten einen anderen Namen vorher?
Artmark, also RT-Mark, Retrusted Trademark.
Wusste ich gar nicht. Die beiden sind auch super. Ich meine, sie sind extrem bekannt geworden. Am bekanntesten sicherlich dieser Media-Stunt, den sie gemacht haben mit der BBC-Übertragungs-Interview von dem angeblichen Dow-Chemical-Vertreter über diese Bopal-Geschichte, wo sie dann, wo er sozusagen für Dow-Chemical auf einmal vor der Kamera stand und gesagt hat, wir finden das ganz furchtbar, was passiert ist und wir nehmen jetzt die ganze Verantwortung, so ganz was Neues. Und die treiben das ja auch immer wieder voran, jetzt hier auch mit dem Fake, den New York Times, dieser Druck und lassen sich am laufenden Meter wieder was Lustiges machen. Ihr kennt die wahrscheinlich auch, nehme ich mal an, trifft sich ja. Ist das so eine ähnliche Herangehensweise, die die an den Tag legen, die ihr da auch verfolgt habt oder seht ihr da schon noch einen Unterschied? Die haben schon auch ein bisschen Auftrag, oder?
Die haben einen ziemlichen Auftrag und das ist auf der einen Seite super, so auf der anderen Seite eben sind Freunde von uns, wir kennen uns schon lang und wir haben auch schon sozusagen lose zusammengearbeitet, weil man halt dann irgendwie zufälligerweise näher vor Ort ist und solche Sachen halt und mal das Faxgerät vom anderen braucht, weil man sich ja nicht so persönlich der Intentitätspreis gibt. Und deshalb, die Leute sind immer durcheinander, weil es gibt bei ihnen einen Andy-Pickel-Bau und bei uns gibt es einen Andreas-Bichel-Bauer, der ursprünglich die gleiche Person war, weil das hat es halt mal für ein Projekt gebraucht und den haben wir dann beide weiterverwendet, weil das ist ja praktisch, wenn man so einen Pseudonym mal hat. Nein, sie sind relativ politisch unterwegs, immer mehr in die Richtung und das ist auch total okay, wenn sie das so machen wollen, aber ich finde es halt, ich finde die ganze amerikanische Kultur und Kunstszene, bis auf die Ausnahme einiger Schauspieler und Musiker, was fast peinlich ist, weil das ihr so Hollywood beschreibt jetzt gerade, total peinlich in Bezug auf die zumindest letzten acht Jahre Bush etc., weil da keine Sau irgendwas gemacht hat. Ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, da waren die eben auch als Elektroniker-Situationen, wo dann die Amis da sind und die sozusagen amerikanische Regierung macht nur noch Wahnsinn herum und die sitzen da und machen geile Flaschapplikationen. Und da denkst du so, vergiss es, es ist vollkommen uninteressant. Und das rennt einfach nicht, das interessiert mich nicht, ob die dann... Ich bin ja auch in Amerika aufgewachsen, eine Zeit lang. Ich kenne es ja auch. Und es ist für mich auch Heimat. Und deshalb betrifft es mich natürlich auch emotional, aber da hört sich mein... Eskapismus, ja, ist schön. Da nehmt Schaumskat sich auch ganz tolle Worte dafür, aber eben, der würde ihm wahrscheinlich... Ich sehe es halt eher so, wie er sagt, das ist einfach eine Unfähigkeit der Sonderklassik. Und dass man danach jetzt irgendwie die New York Times rausbringt, mit irgendwelchen Hoffnungsbotschaften, finde ich... Ich hoffe, es macht Yasmin glücklich, weil ich finde es im Endeffekt nur schwach, muss ich echt sagen.
Aber sie schaffen es natürlich damit auch, eine Medienöffentlichkeit zu erzeugen und auch in gewisser Hinsicht so diese Hysterie, diesen Wahn, den du da beschrieben hast.
Ja und wofür?
Ich weiß nicht, für eine Diskussion um diese Themen.
Nein, du hast vorhin nämlich genau das Wort gesagt und mir gesagt, machen auch lustige Dinge. Und du hast aber vorhin nicht lustig gesagt. Und das ist eben das, was leider Gottes bei ihnen übrig bleibt. So sinnvoll ihre Anliegen sind und so gut sie es auch machen. Am Schluss wird es lustig, weil sie Entertainment-Charakter bekommt, das bekommt Entertainment-Charakter, weil man die Leute mitziehen will und so weiter. Aber das ist einfach nicht Entertaining. Es ist einfach nicht Entertaining. Und das war auch, wir haben auch, nachdem wir auch nach Ford Auction des Öfteren Vorträge gemacht, und ich kam eben auch beim CCC, kann ich mich erinnern, dass da jemand gesagt hat, ah, das ist aber schon irgendwie, schon auch gefährlich. Und dann habe ich gesagt, so ein Scheiß, das war mir nicht gefährlich. Gefährlich ist, wenn du ein Straßenkind in Sao Paulo bist. Das ist gefährlich. Und das muss man sich schon vor Augen halten. Vor allem, wenn man sich in Themen hineinbegibt, wo man halt dann eben, ja huuu, dann sind die Telefone angezapft. Und es tut mir mehr weh, wenn ich mir das Schienbein anhaue. Und das meine ich ernst. Und die Yes-Men haben Vorträge gemacht, da hast du gemerkt, das Publikum findet es natürlich auch lustig. Und es ist nicht lustig. Und deshalb haben wir dann noch ziemlich damit aufgehört, die Vorträge so zu gestalten. Ich war immer schon gern user-unfriendly. Aber das ist der Unterschied, ob man jetzt user-unfriendly ist, wenn man es einfach lustig findet, Leute zu verstören oder weil man eben sagt, es ist wichtig. Es macht auch eine gewisse Überzeugung raus. Und die Yes-Mens sind leider Gottes auch abgetriftet, dass sie dann ihr Publikum entertainen. Und dann lacht das Publikum über das Publikum, das im Video lacht, das das Video anschaut, das das Video anschaut und alle lachen und am Schluss haben sie vergessen, wieso es eigentlich gemacht wird. Und das finde ich etwas tragisch.
Ihr seid ja dann schon auch noch ein bisschen bei diesem Wahlthema auch geblieben mit anderen Projekten. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich jetzt nicht so ganz tief drin stecke, was ihr da alles angegangen seid. Es gab diese Wahlgeld.
Ja, das war später. Wir haben dann eben, wir haben 2000, wir haben andere Sachen gemacht nach VoteAction. Wir haben, die haben nach VoteAction haben wir gemacht, Nazilein mit Christoph Schlingensief gemeinsam. Und dann, aber 2004 sind wir wieder zurück, wir kommen wieder Wahlweinamerika, haben wir dann, das hat geheißen The Agency for, was? Manual Election Recounts. Genau.
Da ging es halt mehr um die Wahlmaschinen in Florida. Also dort, wo es passiert ist. Das war ja übrigens auch der Hammer, weil nach VoteAction, wir wussten dann nicht, was wir machen sollen. Weil wir haben ja angekündigt, wir machen eine Auktion, dann werden die Stimmen verkauft und so. Und dann ist diese Florida Punching Card Sache, wo dann eben der Gore eigentlich gewonnen und der Busch dann sein Bruder und so weiter. Und das war für uns die Lösung, weil wir mussten nichts mehr machen. Die haben wirklich nahtlos übernommen. Und das ist aber auch interessant von der medialen Aufmerksamkeit. Weil man könnte ja verführt werden eben von 500 Millionen Zuschauern. Und wenn du dann von 500 Millionen quasi auf Null runter singst, kann das für eine Person schon irgendwie recht hart sein. Auch wenn es das Projekt betrifft und nicht dich als Person. Aber du bist das Projekt.
Eben war ich da noch so wichtig.
Eben haben mich 100 Journalisten um Tage angerufen. Und von einem Tag auf den anderen Null. Aber wirklich Null.
Nur noch die Staatsanwälte.
Genau, nur noch die Staatsanwälte. Die sagen, wir müssen das jetzt irgendwie lösen. Und können sie uns nicht.
Ich fand das extrem putzig, dass ihr im Prinzip vorher den Betrug der Wahl thematisiert habt. Und alle haben sich unglaublich aufgeregt, wie man denn nur könnte und so weiter. Und danach ist einfach nur noch Betrug der Wahl das Thema.
Das war total geil. Und das war ja dann auch der Aufhänger für das 2004. Da haben wir im Kunsthaus in Graz eine Installation im Medienkunstlabor. Das war damals der Franz Xaver, der Kurator dort. Und da haben wir wirklich, das war auch der Anfang eigentlich unserer bildenden Kunstkarriere, wenn man das so nennen kann. Da haben wir bewusst die erste Ausstellung gemacht, wo wir gesagt haben, wir konzentrieren uns, wir fokussieren uns jetzt nicht auf die Technologie, so wie bis jetzt, Netz und Technologie, sondern wir fokussieren uns jetzt auf Objekte.
Ja, ihr hattet ja auch noch die ganzen Papierstapel hier.
Ja, natürlich, das muss man ja verwenden, das gammelt darum sehr schrecklich.
Und das haben wir danach gemacht. Wir haben eine Papierskulptur gemacht mit, ich glaube, 270.000 Wahlzetteln aus Florida.
Aber da haben wir uns schon wieder welche besorgt gehabt, das stimmt.
Originale?
Nein, die waren nicht originale. Aber als Performance haben wir eine Wahlkarten-Ausfüllaktion gemacht, wo wir die Leute ganzkörper eingekleidet haben mit Handschuhen und CSI-Western und so einen ganzen Scheiss, damit sie keine biologischen Spuren auf diesen Wahlkarten. Weil das waren Originalwahlkarten, die wir uns eher schlichen haben. Du kannst Stimmkarten organisieren, das sind komplizierte Systeme, das geht irgendwie. Wir hatten 40 von denen und haben die Leute, die ausfüllen lassen, die dann verschickt. Und dann 2007 sind wir von Martin Heller aus der Schweiz, der jetzt Linz 09 Kulturhauptstadt-Intendant ist, beauftragt worden, über eine Agentur namens Agent Provocateur gegen ziemlich viel Kohle in der Schweiz das Vote Action nachzubauen, ein Remake zu machen, aber für die schweizerischen Nationalratswahlen. Das haben wir dann durchgezogen und das war total spannend, weil da haben wir das Ganze aufgebaut mit Website usw. Das Vote Action war ein Fake. Wir hatten ja nie vor, Stimmen zu kaufen und zu verkaufen. Und bei Wahlgeld dort kommen, haben wir gesagt, und jetzt ziehen wir es durch, weil ich wollte das schon lang. Ich bin Schweizer, also ich bin Schweizer-Amerikaner, aber in der Schweiz aufgewachsen und ich mag die Schweiz nicht so. Das Bankgeheimnis, Postgeheimnis, 80% Briefwahlanteil, das ist perfekt. Besser kannst du es nicht haben, wenn du das Voterauction real machen willst. Bei Voterauction war es immer klar, das geht eigentlich nicht. Wie willst du nachweisen, dass der auf der Punching-Maschine dann wirklich das gewählt hat, was er und so und die Kohle und der ganze Scheisse. Dort ist es wirklich gegangen und wir haben gesagt, wir machen das. Und die Agent Provocateur wollte von uns aber schriftlich unterschrieben, dass wir es nicht machen, weil es eine Kunstaktion ist. Wir haben gesagt, ja, es ist eine Kunstaktion. Nur, die Kunstaktion besteht halt darin, dass wir wirklich Wahlstimmen kaufen und verkaufen. Und das wurde dann auch angekündigt bei der Bundeskanzlei, oder wie das heißt, da wo die die Wahlen durchführen, haben wir den Schrieb hingeschickt, einen Anwalt, dass das eine Kunstaktion, blabla. Und dann haben wir es durchgezogen und sturm im Wasserglas. Und dann, nach zwölf Stunden, hat irgendein Billig-Recherchemagazin, so eine 20 Minuten heißen die, oder irgendeine Gratis-Zeitung, hat rausgefunden, das sind die gleichen Leute, die Vodafone gemacht haben. Und dann hat es gemacht, blasch. Aber wir haben alles gehabt, also die ganzen Headlines, die ganzen News und die Fernsehnews und ganze Scheiss. Und dann ist es zusammengeflogen und nichts mehr passiert.
Das heißt, ihr hättet euch da sozusagen noch besser tarnen müssen?
Das war nicht die Absicht, wir wollten das nicht, weil die Tarnung war ja, es war wie Counterintelligence. Es war wie so, wir tun jetzt so, als würden wir uns tarnen. Dann fliegen wir auf, so dass sie sagen können, es ist Kunst, weil wir müssen ja auffliegen, sonst würden sie ja glauben, wir machen es richtig. Dadurch, dass wir auffliegen, schaut es dann plötzlich so aus, ah, das sind ja Künstler, die machen das sicher nicht richtig. Und dadurch konnten wir im Hintergrund das richtig machen. Und wir haben es auch gemacht.
Und was hatte das dann für ein Turnaround?
Von der Kohle her?
Naja, also ich meine, wie viele Leute haben dann tatsächlich versucht, eine Wahlstimme zu kaufen?
Wie viele waren es, genau? Hunderte.
Ja, das waren nur ein paar, ich glaube 400. Also 400 war eben für den Aufwand sehr, sehr effizient, würde ich sagen.
400 und dann 70 Schweizer Franken war die Stimme. Und dann haben wir sie verkauft und blockern einen Käufer. Aber wir haben die, die, die, die, wir haben... Das war das Geilste. Wir haben die nicht bezahlt. Wir haben sie, wir haben die Stimmen entgegengenommen, Postfach in der Schweiz, da wurden sie reingeschickt. Wir haben ihnen das bestätigt und gesagt, ja, wir zahlen euch dann. Dann haben wir sie verkauft, die Kohle kassiert, aber die haben wir nie ausgezahlt. Weil wir uns auf den Stamm umgestellt haben, ja, ich meine, was willst du machen? Wie ist sonst verklärt?
Ja, aber die haben das... Ich kriege bis vor einem halben Jahr, habe ich immer wieder noch von ein paar Leuten so Pseudodromails bekommen. Ja, also sie würden sich jetzt schon fragen, wo ihr Geld bleiben würde und sie hätten doch irgendwie... Und du denkst, wie blöd sind die Leute? Aber so, so blöd sind sie, ja?
Also es war finanziell doppelt interessantes Projekt.
Und da haben sie uns auch gefragt, wieso habt ihr das Projekt machen können? Wirklich wegen des Geldes, ja?
Ja, das war ein Geldprojekt, das ist richtig. Und das war es dann aber mit den Wahlen. Es war nicht so, dass wir jetzt gesagt haben, das ist jetzt programmatisch.
Diese Agency for Manual Election Recounts, das war jetzt nur im Rahmen dieser Ausstellung sozusagen.
Ja, diese Ausstellung.
Diese Performance und die Ergelungen.
Mehr Wahl gab es nicht. Dieses Projekt, das du angesprochen hast, mit Schlingensief zusammen, Nazilein.
Ich meine, jeder Künstler muss mal was zu den Nazis machen.
Ja, mit Deutsch. Vor allem, wenn man Hans Bernhard hat.
Genau, und die Amerikaner dürfen auch, aber das ist dann eben halt so semi peinlich. Das ist was anderes, das ist klar. Das dachten wir uns dann auch, dass man das akademisch auch durchrexerziert. Nein, und es war auch relativ abstrakt, weil wir arbeiten ja sehr chaotisch miteinander zusammen. Sprich, wir sprechen uns nicht miteinander ab. Oft ist es so, jetzt nicht mehr ganz so. Aber wir haben eigentlich immer so gearbeitet, dass ich prima in der Nacht, er tagsüber und in zwei verschiedenen Städten und so weiter. Also wirklich total chaotisch. Und das bringt natürlich sehr viel Dynamik in das Ganze rein und macht es einfach viel, viel besser. Das kann man natürlich nicht zu siebt machen, es gab aber zu zweit geht das. Und dann wollten wir eigentlich wissen, wie gut das funktioniert. Weil eben der Schlingensief macht teilweise ähnliche Sachen wie wir, aber natürlich in ganz anderen Umfällen. Wir wollten einfach wissen, ob das irgendwie zusammenpasst oder nicht. Also vorweggenommen passt überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Oder wir machen ähnliche Sachen wie ihr.
Richtig, Entschuldigung, ich habe vollkommen falsch formuliert. Richtig, genau. Aber es war gute Zusammenarbeit. Was habt ihr gemacht? Das Thema war eigentlich Vorurteile.
Da habe ich irgendwie das Gefühl.
Nein, es ging darum. 2001 gab es in Deutschland, ich habe damals auch noch in Berlin gewohnt, die große Hysterie wegen vielen, vielen Neonazis. Diese vielen, vielen Neonazis waren perfekt, um von dem anderen Problem Arbeitslosigkeit abzulenken. Da gab es verschiedene Regierungsprogramme. Vor allem das eine ist raus, das andere Exit, mit Websites, die dann die aussteigwillige Neonazis ködern sollten, um auszusteigen aus der Neonazi-Szene. Der Köder war im Endeffekt Geld, nämlich für jeden aussteigendem Neonazi. Es gab so ein Budget von 4.000-5.000 Mark in die Richtung. Es war nicht so wenig Geld. Ein Jahr war abgedeckt. Locationwechsel, neue Wohnung, neuer Job, Geld für ein Jahr so in die Richtung.
Das war jetzt ein leeres Versprechen?
Nein, nein, das gab es. Das gab es in echt. Und es wurde auch exorziert.
Das war natürlich ein Bullenscheisse. Das war reine Bullenscheisse. Und die Stäne ist sowieso zu 50 Prozent infiltriert von Bullen. Also von...
Genau, kann man doppelt kassieren.
Ich bin Bulle, ich steige aus.
Von Umgetretenen oder Spitzeln, nennt man das.
Es war so ein Grundzeugenprogramm. Und das konnte man auch ganz toll vermarkten. Man hat es jetzt so ganz explizit, wie es jetzt erklärt hat, vermarkten. Das ist klar. Und die Websites waren auch grauenhaft. So halt Websites, wie es halt irgendwelche politischen Parteien und Ämter machen. Also in Nationalfarben und Weiß und grauenhafte Fonds.
Nazi-Problem gelöst, wir kaufen sie einfach aus.
Richtig. Auch genau, wenn man sagt, genau mit solchen Argumenten fängt man nämlich Leute, die moralisch am Sand sind, mit Geld. Das löst das nicht mehr. Also grauenhaft. Echt schlimm. Jedenfalls haben wir dann gesagt, gut, da machen wir jetzt auch ein Neonazi-Aussteiger-Projekt. Also eigentlich hat der Christoph, der Schlingensiefer, als erstes auf die Sache gekommen, weil der wurde schon seit Jahren angekniet vom Zentrum für politische Bildung, dass er doch mal was macht zum Nazi-Thema oder Neonazi-Thema. Irgendwie halt so was in die Richtung.
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung.
Und dann hat er in Zürich Hamlet inszeniert und hat wahrscheinlich einfach noch extra Kohle dafür gebraucht. Dann hat er gedacht, den ist dann verkauft, ja das machen wir jetzt und so weiter. Und dann sind wir mehr oder weniger zufällig zusammengekommen und dass wir dann halt jetzt irgendwie diese online Plattform starten, um Neonazis zu suchen für sein Theaterprojekt. Und dann haben wir uns eben diese Sache angeschaut, haben wir gesehen, wir machen ein generelles Aussteigerprogramm.
Also ihr wolltet sozusagen richtige Neonazis haben, die er dann in seinem Stück verwenden lassen.
Genau, im Hamlet gibt es ein Stück im Stück und da sollten die so vier bis acht Neonazis dann...
Die sollten auch einen Job kriegen.
Ausgestiegene, genau.
Das war ein Job und integriert im Ensemble und in Ziel.
Arbeit macht Freiheit, ja. Und das hab ja nicht ich erfunden. Und ich auch. Und ja, dann haben wir halt diese... Und ich hab mir gedacht, gut, wie fängt man denn eine Neonazi natürlich mit seinen Marketing- Schlüsselreizen... Also wir haben halt diese Nazilein-Website gemacht in den Farben Weiß, Schwarz-Rot, wie sich das gehört, damit sich der User zu Hause fühlt. Und haben dann halt auch Flugzettel verteilen lassen durch unsere User. Und die dann halt auf Nazi-Aufmärsche gegangen sind in Ostdeutschland, teilweise dort solche Zettel verteilt, da haben die Leute... Man muss auch mutig sein, das in Ostdeutschland damals zu machen. Also waren coole Leute auch dabei, die sich da so finden, was sich halt im Web immer so findet, das ist immer erstaunlich.
Ich kann mir eine Nacht erinnern, wo wir mit dem Bus von meinem Freund, von meinem Stuntman aus Berlin, sind wir durch Marzand durch und haben so kissenweise Flyer abgeworfen und dann okay, Gas geben, schnell raus. Weil dort war es wirklich gefährlich, das war das 2001, oder?
Ja, jedenfalls, und dann...
Was stand drauf auf dem Flyer?
Aussteigen willige Neonazis melden, Sucht, Job, Jobgeld, alles.
Und habt ihr dann welche gefunden?
Ja, jetzt wirst du erzählen.
Das Casting im Boot Lab.
Wir haben im Boot Lab ein Casting gemacht. Das Boot Lab ist ja ein total netter Ort. Das alte Telekom-Gebäude war damals da in Mitte. Und waren lauter coole Leute.
Also Berlin, muss man sagen?
Berlin, Entschuldigung, ja. Und Mitte in einem anderen Stadt. Da waren ganz coole Leute, muss ich wirklich sagen. Aber manche taten sich schwer mit diesen, eigentlich Ex-Neonazis zu dem Zeitpunkt ja schon. Und das hat mich total verwundert, weil ich dachte, wenn ein Neonazi ist böse, dann ist der Ex-Neonazi wieder gut. Vor allem für den linksstehenden. Aber das ist irgendwie alles komplexer, als ich mir dachte anscheinend. Aber egal. Da kamen dann halt so an drei Tagen hintereinander dann ins Boot Lab, das ja schräg gegenüber von einer Synagoge ist. Und deshalb auch überall lauter Bullen in Zivil und in Echt stehen, die alles überwachen und so weiter. Da kamen dann so die Neonazis daher, die natürlich jetzt halt ausschauen, wie der Neonazi, den ihr jetzt alle im Kopf Bild vor, irgendwie da drinnen habt. Sondern die schauen halt irgendwie ganz unterschiedlich aus und ganz normal. Und haben die unterschiedlichsten Motivationen, wie sie kommen und wieso die Neonazis waren oder noch immer teilweise sind. Und das war schon relativ heavy, muss ich sagen.
Was habt ihr denn dann gemacht mit denen?
Ja, ich hab mit denen halt gesprochen, weil man muss ja immer, muss ich wissen, ist das jetzt jemand, der mich nur übers Ohr hauen will? Oder das muss der prinzipiell mal wissen, egal um welches Business es geht.
Da muss ich erst mal rausfinden, ob der überhaupt ein richtiger Nazi war.
Richtig, dann. Das hab ich mich im Vorhinein auch... Nein, das war es schon, wie das geht. Das hat mir mein Großvater beigebracht. Aber nein, ich hab mir auch so abstrakte Fragen vorgestellt. Und dann, wie ich in der Situation war, hab ich gemerkt, es ist relativ einfach. Ja, also die Leute, die nicht irgendwie total psychos sind, die sind keine.
Also, psycho müssen sie schon mal sein.
Ja, aber nicht psycho in dem Sinne, dass du dir denkst, vor dem hab ich Angst, oder der ist mir jetzt zu unangenehm, weil der ist total psycho. Sondern dass du denkst, der weiß selber, dass er nicht funktioniert. Und der weiß selber, dass er ein Gehirn-Krüppel ist. Sagen wir mal so.
Wie äußert sich das dann? Wie merkt man, dass der das weiß, dass er einer ist? Oder dass er sich selbst als einer empfindet?
Indem man es auch formuliert. Eine der schlimmsten Sachen, die ich mitkriege, die habe ich wirklich arg gefunden, ist, dass eigentlich 80 Prozent aller Leute, mit denen ich geredet habe, das ist eigentlich so Hans, das ist Sache mir meine, dass die alle gesagt haben, dass das jetzt so toll war, so zu reden, weil sie noch nie so ein offenes Gespräch führen konnten. Und das ist natürlich echt schlimm. Echt schlimm. Weil du denkst, ja, und gleichzeitig weißt du, dass der verdammte Staat die Leute mit Geld rauskaufen will.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen was vom Psychiater.
Ja, das ist schon eine Fähigkeit von mir. Das kann ich schon ganz gut, das weiß ich auch. Es gibt auch so Leute, die sitzen irgendwo, und dann kommt irgendjemand, der erzählt ihnen die Liebesgeschichte. Ich bin einer von denen, mir erzählen die Leute immer alles.
Heute drehe ich den Spieß um.
Ja, eben wie gesagt, alles glauben. Und ja, das waren schon heavy Leute dabei. Und dann war natürlich auch einer dabei, der eben gar nicht ins Profil gepasst hat, obwohl es nicht ein Profil gab, aber es gab halt so drei verschiedene Charaktere, die so prinzipiell kommen sind. Eben von dem einen Typen, der eigentlich auch so der verkappte Homosexuelle mit leichter Pädophilie diese Abteilung oder der total politisch interessierte, der einmal extremer linker war, dann wieder extremer rechter, dann in der Mitte und jetzt wieder rechts und jetzt wieder raus. So diese Sachen. Da war ein ganz geiler Typ, der war eben ganz links. Er war ganz normal, dann war er ganz links. Dann hat er gefunden, das ist alles total intelligent, was die Leute da zusammenbringen und denken gut nach. Aber die machen nichts. Die sitzen immer nur und quatschen. Deshalb dachte er sich, ich gehe zu den Rechten. Und nach ein paar Jahren musste er feststellen, die machen ganz viel, aber die denken überhaupt nicht nach. Und ich bin noch tagsamer, vom Fan bis zum Schluss gekommen, dass man einfach in der Mitte bleibt, aber er ist nie wirklich zu dem Schluss gekommen. Oder dann die anderen, die sich selber eigentlich als sie aktiv waren, als sie mich schlimm selber empfunden haben, aber gemerkt haben, dass die Gesellschaft eigentlich sie braucht. Also eben, mal stelle ich es sich vor, du bist in einem kleinen Ort irgendwo in Ostdeutschland. Das war primär Ostdeutschland, aber wir waren in Berlin. Und dann bist du ein Neonati, weil du bist halt ein Neonati, weil deine Kollegen auch welche sind. Ich meine, es sind Teenager. Und dann ist das Problem natürlich, das blöde ist, wenn du Neonazi bist und es sind keine Ausländer im Ort. Und dann, was machst du dann? Du sagst, okay, dann geben wir gegen die Drogendealer vor, weil die sind auch böse. Und dann, das ist ja das eine. Und das andere ist ja der Neonazi per se hat ja ein Problem im Staat. Das gehört ja auch zum Programm dazu. Wenn jetzt aber der Staat, was sagt der Neonazi? Der Neonazi sagt, der Staat ist korrupt und funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Und das ist alles nur verwaschendes Getue. Und dann ist die Neonazitruppe im Ort und agiert gegen die Drogendealer, sprich prügelt die Drogendealer zusammen, etc. Und die Polizei geht aber nicht gegen die Neonazis vor, oder in dem Kontext Gewalttäter, sondern schaut absichtlich weg, weil ja die Neonazis das Problem lösen. Damit bestätigt ja sich wiederum das Urteil der Neonazis, dass der Staat total korrupt ist.
Weil sie müssen ja eigentlich auf sie einschlagen.
Richtig, weil eigentlich sind viele von den Leuten, die da eben Neonazis waren, sehr sehr interessiert an einem ernsthaften Staat und nicht an einem Verlogenen. Was ja das öfteren passiert bei Leuten, die sehr wohl auch politisch interessiert sind. Das Angebot an jungen linken Gruppierungen ist halt auch nicht immer so groß in manchen Orten. Und es ist auch nicht immer so cool an manchen Orten. Und dann gab es auch ein paar unterschiedliche Leute. Aber ich meine, es ist klar, wenn du mal bei Sachen dabei warst, die halt relativ arg sind, eben so dieses, ich weiß nicht, ob das den Leuten bekannt ist, dieses Bordsteinbeißen, oder? Und wenn du da mal in den Gezug geschaut hast, da bist du halt nachher kaputt. Ich meine, das geht halt nicht. Du kannst nicht bei solchen Sachen mitmachen und nachher noch immer ein lustiges Mitglied der Konsumgesellschaft sein. Das geht nicht und das merkt man Leuten auch an. Ich verstehe auch, dass die sich dann darüber freuen, weil man mit ihnen trotzdem normal redet, aber es ist trotzdem echt irgendwie grauenhaft.
Ich muss nur kurz dazwischen werfen. Das aktuellste Projekt, das wir im Moment machen, heißt Super Enhanced 2009. Da geht es um Folter, Enhanced Interrogations. Wir haben Kontakt gehabt mit verschiedenen Veteranen. Wir haben auch hier in unserem Atelier einen Monat lang einen Gefängniswärter aus Guantanamo Bay gehabt, mit dem wir gesprochen haben und Fotos gemacht, Performance und so zeigst. Da haben wir plötzlich gemerkt, und auch noch der Nazi-Großvater, und plötzlich ist klar geworden, die Parallelen sind total gross zwischen den Typen. Das war irgendwie krass. Einerseits sind sie total kaputt, weil sie Zeugs mitgemacht haben im Krieg oder in Guantanamo oder so, oder Bagramm oder so. Die du nicht mehr oder nur mit sehr viel Hilfe verarbeiten kriegst. Und das andere ist die Victimologie, wenn man das so nennen kann. Es ist eigentlich nichts Schlimmes passiert. Und ich bin aber das Opfer, eben durch diese Sachen, die man nicht wegkriegt. Also ich, ich, ich, ich, ich. Und wenn du sie drauf ansprichst, die richtigen Opfer, also ich nenne sie mal die richtigen Opfer, die Kinder, die erschossen wurden, die Männer, die entführt wurden und gefoltert und sieben Jahre im Gefängnis stecken, ohne dass sie wissen, wo es hingeht und so weiter. Die Familien, die ausgelöscht wurden, die existieren nicht. Und wenn du sie drauf ansprichst, werden sie ultra aggressiv und kippen völlig um. Also das war dort die Parallelität.
Ja, obwohl man sagen muss, die waren auch ein paar Leute dabei, die eher so waren. Das war aber die Minderheit, die Mehrheit waren eben Leute, die das nicht gehabt haben. Und dann merkst du, das waren richtige Aussteiger, die halt wirklich ein schlechtes Gewissen hatten, das auch äußerten und auch sagten, okay, ihnen ist eh nicht mehr zu helfen, sie brauchen nicht weiter noch Scheiße machen. Aber eben, das sieht man jetzt bei dem alten Nazi-Großvater wirst du das nicht hören. Und der Guantanamo Werther war jetzt aber eher beim alten Nazi-Großvater als beim aussteigwilligen Neonazi. Und so kann man es sich einordnen. Aber es war allerdings immer noch einer dabei, der hat überhaupt nicht ins Profil gepasst damals. Der hat dann irgendwie gemeint, er wäre der Anwalt von einem aussteigwilligen Typen und er wird sich das jetzt mal anschauen wollen. Er werde ihm geschickt werden von seinem Mandanten und so weiter. Und mein Vater ist Rechtsanwalt. Und den Rechtsanwalt erkenne ich auf 100 Meter gegen den Wind. Und das war aber kein Rechtsanwalt. Er hat nicht so gesprochen. Die können ja gar nicht anders reden, als Rechtsanwälte sprechen, oder? Also das war eindeutig ein Polizeispitzel. Und das war natürlich total lustig. Und ich dachte, toll, du kannst mir jetzt alles fragen, was du willst, aber ich erfahre ja nur, weil du weißt ja nicht, dass ich weiß.
Das war sehr servus.
Nein, den haben wir nicht gecastet.
Den Qualifier.
Nein, aber er war sehr süß, mit seinen Fragen, die er gestellt hat.
Was hat er denn gefragt?
Das kann ich da jetzt nicht so wiedergeben, aber halt total naive Sachen, er war halt total unkaputt. Allerdings, was ja dann nachher noch kam, das Zentrum für politische Bildung, das Bundeszentral für politische Bildung, Entschuldigung, Volksfonds von Judäa und so weiter.
Und die haben ja...
Nein, wir haben ja, damit wir das Naziland besser vermarkten können, eine Parallel-Website zur deutschen Innenministerium gemacht. Wir haben keine Kopie gemacht, sondern wir haben nur ein Skript mit dem anderen gemeinsam produziert, das die Website vom Innenministerium gepaarsed hat on user demand. Aus Rechtsgründen haben wir gepaarsed und nicht kopiert. Und dort haben wir halt irgendwie ein paar Informationen ausgetauscht und halt auch unsere Announcements reingestellt. Und dadurch, dass es ein besseres Domain war als die, die das selbst hatten, wurde das auch total abgekauft, dass das das Echte ist. Und da die Bundeszentrale das Projekt real gefördert hat, war es natürlich wirklich schwierig zu erkennen, was da jetzt stimmt und was nicht. Und da wurde ich dann aber hin zitiert, also eigentlich freundlich eingeladen. Und dann war ich dort und eben, dass sie mit mir das Projekt besprechen will und sie wird uns auch gemalt kennenlernen, weil sie bis jetzt noch Kontakt mit dem Herrn Schlinge und sie fadten und bla bla bla und Säusel Säusel, Honig Honig. Und dann komme ich hin und wir sagen irgendwie grüß Gott und so, also siehe her, guten Tag. Und dann knallte mir irgendwie so drei Ausdrucke von der eben BMDI website auf dem Tisch und sagt, und was ist das? Und ich schaue sie an und sage, das sind ausgedruckte Pixel, offensichtlich. Und ich meine, ich meine es ja wirklich, das sind ja ausgedruckte Pixel. Ist ja alles frei erfunden, was soll das blöde Gespräch? Und dann hat die mir in dem Gespräch, der probierte mich da irgendwie so unter Druck zu setzen, das ist halt irgendwie echt immer sehr lächerlich, wie will man da mit Druck erzeugen? Und ja, weil sie könnten uns anklagen wegen was? Hoheitszeichen, Missbrauch und so weiter, weil halt irgendwie Bundesadler drauf sind und so weiter. Lächerlich, weil ich habe gesagt, ja, wir sind eben, wenn man ja schon Schulden hat, dann ist es ja wurscht, weil du kannst ja nicht mehr als verschuldet sein.
Aber die dumme Nuss wollte dich ja nur bestechen.
Ja, das war ja dann der Witz. Dann hat sie mir eben gesagt, deshalb weiß ich, wie viel Geld man eben kriegen konnte als Neonazi. Sie hat mir dann das Angebot gemacht. Sie hat gesagt, sie würde, aber wenn sie da nicht weiterkommt, hat sie gemeint, ja, aber wir hätten doch jetzt Kommunikation mit den Neonazis, ob sie da sozusagen mithorchen könnten. Da haben wir gedacht, na sicher, ja, da würden sich alle da fallen. Ich habe gesagt, nein, das glaube ich ist keine gute Idee, hat sie gemeint, ja, aber, und auch wegen Briefgeheimnis. Sie hat gemeint, ja, aber fangt das Briefgeheimnis nicht erst an, wenn man zurückschreibt. Ach, kreativ ist sie, aber Stimmen tut es trotzdem nicht. Und dann hat sie gemeint, ja, weil, also sie könnte uns nur das Angebot machen, weil es würde ja dieses Programm geben, mit so unserer viel Mark oder pro Aussteigewilligen, dass wir für jeden Aussteigewilligen, den wir sozusagen produzieren, der in das Programm reingeht, einfach eine Provision mitschneiden könnten. So halt um die 30 Prozent, ja.
Also heutzutage...
Sie gehörte selber zu...
Bundeszentrale für politische Richter.
Und damals habe ich, aber heutzutage würde ich natürlich sofort annehmen, ja, sehr klar, ja. Allerdings, wie gesagt, es waren Neonazi-Projekte und ich hatte gerade Gespräche mit denen und habe gedacht, ich möchte nicht mit denen rumficken, sicher, sicher nicht. Und also ich habe es angeboten.
Wie viele Leute hast du dann gecastet aus dieser Truppe?
Also das waren so, am Schluss waren zwölf in der engen Auswahl und ich weiss jetzt nicht mehr, wer es dann real so wie dabei war.
Und die sind dann tatsächlich, die sind dann gegangen und haben dann gespielt.
Genau, und haben Straßenaktionen mit Christoph gemacht und so weiter. Wir waren auch im Ding, am Theatertreffen in Berlin und im Bundestag oben in der Kuppel mit Presseterminen und Rätsel Schlauch und die ganzen Fuzzis waren dort und irgendwie. Dann gab es eine Podiumsdiskussion, da bin ich ausgezuckt im Volkstheater, weil da haben sie nur von Kohle geredet, wirklich. Die blöden Politiker, der Rätsel Schlauch und der SPD-Politiker und nur Kohle, Kohle, Kohle. Wir müssen Kohle investieren, Kohle, Kohle, Kohle. Irgendwann bin ich aufgeschrieben und habe nur noch herumgeschrien und gesagt, ihr seid solche Arschlöcher, Wichser. Und es war pervers, weil du brauchst wirklich, du brauchst drei, vier Monate recherchieren, du brauchst ein bisschen mit den Leuten reden. Nicht mal direkt, nur indirekt. Und du weißt, was Sache ist. Und die haben keine Ahnung gehabt. Und dann haben wir halt, zum Abschließen noch an dem Projekt, wir haben dann gemerkt, wir haben keine Chance. Da schlingen sie als Brand im deutschsprachigen Raum, da muss jetzt gar nichts mehr wollen nebendran. Da muss nicht mal eine Erwähnung wollen. Und wir haben dann gesagt, okay, aber wir haben ja unsere eigene Zielgruppe, wir können irgendwie, wir können das auf ein Level raufsetzen und wir haben dann eine Website gebaut, internationale Corporation konstruiert, die Hate Crime Consulting macht. Und das dann angeboten und die Kampagne schlingen sie, war dann eine Kampagne, um diese Corporation zu promoten. Das haben wir dann so abgerundet und gemacht.
Ja, bei euch spielt auf jeden Fall immer das Internet auch irgendwie eine Rolle, gerade mit dem Content und dieses Webseiten extrahieren, neue Darstellen, kopieren, so tun als ob, scheint ja ein wiederkehrendes Ding zu sein, irgendwie habt ihr das gefressen, so ein bisschen auch, das Netz. Da gibt es ja noch diesen Injunction Generator, IPNIC, das Internet Partnership for No Internet Content. Worum dreht es sich dabei?
Das IPNIC ist eigentlich die Plattform, auf der die Generators laufen, also das ist eine Tetralogie, vier Stück gibt es bis jetzt und der Injunction Generator war der erste. Das war eine Reaktion auf die Gerichtsurteile, die dann in der Schweiz bei E-Mail-Versand unsere Domains abgewirkt haben. Wir haben gesagt, wir regnen uns aber nicht auf oder gehen juristisch dagegen vor, weil eben das E im I-Cant-Board und es wird juristisch. Es gibt diverseste juristische Schriften, hunderte von Seiten über das Problem, das wir gehabt haben. Das ist genügend, das ist gemähte Wiesen. Aber affirmativ gedacht, wenn wir jetzt selber eine Engine bauen, die ein Formular, da kann man ausfüllen, wen man verklagt, welche Domäne man unternehmen will usw.
Das war bei NaziLine. Bei NaziLine hatten wir eine Liste von Sponsoren auf der Website. Da kam alles drauf, was einem da so einfällt. Die Bundeszentrale natürlich, aber auch BASF, Siemens und Bayer.
Die haben aber nichts damit zu tun hatten.
Die haben gar nichts mit Narzissmus zu tun. Die hatten niemals, nein.
BASF ist ein richtiger Holocaust-Leugner.
Bayer auch nicht.
Das wäre zum guten Ton.
BASF gab es noch gar nicht.
Das ist eine andere Rechtsform, das hat nichts miteinander zu tun. Ich glaube, das war von Bayer. Da hat sich jemand gemeldet und hat gemeint, sie würden da nicht um sein wollen und so weiter. Dann haben wir gesagt, ja gut, das ist kein Problem. Deshalb haben wir dann eine Nicht-Sponsorenliste auch gemacht. Dann haben die gemeint, sie wollen auch nicht auf der Nicht-Sponsorenliste um sein. Dann haben wir eine Nicht-Nicht-Sponsorenliste. Dann haben sie sich eigentlich nicht mehr gemeldet. Das war so eine Methode. Bis später gab es dann eine ähnliche Situation mit, das war dann, glaube ich, Bayer, vorwärts BSF, glaube ich. Die haben da auch irgendwie gesagt, sie hätten gesehen, dass ihre Firma uns da sponsoren würde. Wer denn, welche Abteilung bei ihnen das gemacht hat, sie hätten da überhaupt keinen Überblick. Es wäre ihnen jetzt unklar. Ich habe gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht. Da muss ich mal nur fragen, bei welcher Abteilung von uns da eigentlich gesponsert wurde.
Dann haben wir ihnen jetzt Formulare geschickt, die sie ausfüllen müssen.
Genau, da gibt es auch diese geilen Formulare, die du ausfüllen musst, wenn du eine Domainübertragung machen willst. Alles kannst du online machen, aber nicht diese paar scheiß Sachen. Dann musst du auf einmal wieder bei der Post stehen und das verdammte Fax schicken und so weiter, weil das ist ja irgendwie gold anscheinend.
Also mittlerweile geht das, aber es war ein Drama.
Ja, es war ein Drama. Und deshalb haben wir doch das gleiche. Wir dachten, ihr könnt das alles ändern. Ich mache eine Website und ich glaube, ihr könnt irgendwas ändern. Das rennt ja so nicht. Also ich dachte, das ist kein Problem. Hab das super komplexe Form gemacht, irgendwie so drei, vier Seiten lang, mit lauter Blödsinn zum Eintragen, wo du unglaublich lange recherchieren musst. Und das musste man dann dreifach ausfertigen, 27-mal unterschreiben lassen, von geeidet Zuständigen und dann an die und die Nummer faxen. Das war eben das Universal Content and or Domain Removal Form. Und aus dem entstand dann... Genau, wo man dann gesagt hat, das kann man auch automatisieren.
Dort kannst du halt einfach automatisiert Injunctions rausschicken. Die schauen dann wirklich aus wie amerikanische Gerichtsurteile. Da steht alles drin, Kinderpornografie oder irgendwas. Und die Domain, und das wird dann halt an Juristen geschickt, an die Domain-Registry, an ein paar Journalisten und so weiter. Das war der erste Generator. Der zweite war dann der Bankstatement Generator. Weil aus der persönlichen Finanzkrise raus von uns, haben wir gemerkt, ob wir jetzt einen guten oder schlechten Tag haben, hängt irgendwie von zwei blöden Pixeln ab. Nämlich gerade mal ein Minus oder eben kein Minus auf dem Bankkontoauszug. Und haben gesagt, wir generieren einfach Bankauszüge. Die kann man dann verwenden, wie man will. Das war der zweite. Der dritte war ein Psychos-Generator. Das ist ein Online-Psychiater, der dann Rezepte ausstellt, automatisiert. Und der vierte ist der Super-Enhanced-Generator. Das ist das aktuellste Projekt, eben auch mit dem Guantanamo-Typen und dem ganzen Research um Extraordinary Rendition, also Entführungen, Enhanced Interrogations, aber auch Supermax-Prisons und Kinder in Gefängnissen und so. Das ist eine Verhörsoftware. Das ist Know-how von den ganzen Verhörsituationen in diesen amerikanischen Militärgefängnissen, aber auch sonst Polizeiverhörer und so. Und da gehst du durch und es ist ein riesiger Cluster von Fragen mit vorgegebenen Antworten. Das ist die erste Version.
Hier hängt so ein grosses Diagramm an der Wand.
Genau. Und das können wir dynamisch ändern. Es gibt ein paar Ausgänge. Und man muss wirklich richtig antworten. Wenn du nicht richtig antworten, wir machen ein Performance-System mit. Wir fassen Leute in Stresspositionen am Boden und befragen sie mit der Software. Das sind diese vier Generators.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist das Ergebnis des Generators eine Vorschrift, wie man foltert? Nein, es ist ein Verhör. Es ist ein Endergebnis mit Antworten, was da gelaufen ist.
Es ist vermischt. Es ist von der Methode ein Verhör. Also eine semi-enhanced interrogation. Es kommt darauf an, wie kooperativ die Leute sind. Wo man es macht und so weiter, wie weit man da halt irgendwie gehen kann. Und vom Inhaltlichen setzt es sich teilweise und kommt darauf an, was man eben für Antworten gibt. Es setzt sich teilweise auch mit dem Thema per se auseinander, aber nicht zwingend. Es kommt einfach darauf an. Wenn man eben Mahmood Achmalat heißt, dann wird man keine Fragen zu Folter per se bekommen, weil dann muss man andere Fragen beantworten.
Du heißt auch nicht Mahmood, ja?
Ich habe auch nicht richtig zugehört.
Du heißt Hans Bernhard. Es wird nur gefragt, in welchem Trakt du folterst.
Ja, richtig, genau.
Sind die Handschellen lang genug?
Ja, habt ihr ja auch so. Also, Internet lasst euch nicht los. Und auch diese Wirtschaftsgeschichte ist jetzt auch noch nicht so lange her, nicht wahr? Mit diesem, was war das?
Das ist mein absolutes Lieblingsprojekt. Weil es so einfach ist. Es hat aber ein Jahr gedauert, das Scheißkonzept irgendwie zu nageln. Und das ist der erste Teil einer Trilogie von 2005 bis 2009. Der Google Will Eat Itself ist ein autokannibalistischer Prozess. Also wir haben 50 versteckte Websites. Und wir haben eine Armee von kleinen Software-Scrapes-Robotern, die halt auf diese Websites gehen, diese Websites anschauen und ab und zu auf diese Google Advertisements draufklicken. Jedes Mal, wenn die Software, der Agent oder der Roboter einen Klick setzt, kriegen wir ein Micropayment. 10 Cent, 50 Cent, 1 Euro. Das wird gesammelt und Ende Monat überweist uns, Google, dieses Geld auf einen Schweizer Bankkonto. Das Bankkonto ist so konfiguriert, dass es automatisch Google-Aktien kauft, sobald genügend Kohle da ist. Das ist eben dieser autokannibalistische Prozess. Google eats itself oder Google will eat itself. Mittlerweile haben wir fast schon eine halbe Million US-Dollar im Portfolio. Das geht rauf und runter mit der Kurve, je nachdem, wie der Google-Aktienwert sich findet. Aber es ist auf der anderen Seite auch ein rein konzeptionelles Piece, weil es würde 200 Millionen Jahre dauern, die ganze Corporation zu übernehmen.
Außer man liegt es breit an.
Oh, bei der derzeitigen Click-Rate.
Nein, nein, nein, wir können das nicht höher machen.
Click-Capacity würde ich sagen.
Nein, das kannst du, wir reden hier von einem Parasiten, der das Potenzial hat, das System abzuzerstören. Im Prinzip ist das System eh schon morbide, weil man sagt, 30-50% der Klicks sind sowieso fraudulent. In einer oder anderen, russische Cyber-Mafia oder was auch immer, Hausfrauen-Click-Netzwerke, von was auch immer wir reden. Aber das ist so. Google ist so scheissegal, solange es, und das ist das Problem mit dem Projekt, deshalb haben wir auch juristische Probleme mit ihnen gekriegt. Solange niemand darüber redet, Google verdient bei jedem fraudulent Click genauso mit. Das heisst, ihnen ist es in dem Sinn egal. Und auf der anderen Seite, sobald es medial wird, und das war natürlich der Zweck des Projektes...
Sie dachte, es geht jetzt wirklich um die Alterssicherung.
Es geht nur um die Technologie und die Alterssicherung.
Das ist ja nicht unser Geld.
Das Geld gehört ja wieder Google.
Ja klar, wir verwenden das Geld nicht. Nein, es gibt ja eine Grenze.
Das können wir ja nicht machen, das wäre dann wirklich Betrug.
Das wäre Betrug, das heißt, wir lassen das Geld liegen.
Wem gehört denn das Geld dann?
Google to the people. Das ist dann irgendwie die Leute, die sich dafür registriert haben. Nein, das ist ja auch gar kein Geld. Ich meine, Geld ist was anderes.
Das sind Google-Aktien.
Na ja, aber eine halbe Million.
Aber es ist ja nicht wirklich Geld.
Wenn wir es schaffen, das habe ich mir noch nie überlegt. Können wir sie doch verkaufen? Nein, wenn wir es schaffen, die Firma zu zerstören, ist das Geld auch weg, weil sie Aktien sind. Das ist gut. Das habe ich mir so noch gar nicht überlegt. Also, liebe CCC-Leute und andere Interessierte, es braucht einfach viele Parasiten. Wir können das System übernehmen, wir geben die Software nicht raus.
Es braucht eigentlich gar keine Software. Wir haben die Software eigentlich intensiv verwendet, weil solange wir es so gemacht haben, dass wir einfach den Leuten gesagt haben, bitte klickt hier, wir verwenden Geld dann so, haben die Leute viel zu viel geklickt. Und dann hat es dieses Fragilent. Deshalb haben wir das Software technisch gelöst. Also Fragilent erst gemacht, weil echt Fragilent ausgeschattet hat.
Über 3% Klick... Über 3% von Hunden...
Die Menschlichkeit ist bei Google geregelt.
Ja, die stellen sich automatisiert, aber da kannst du noch nichts machen.
Über 3% Klicks bist du bei Google ein Roboter. Das kann jetzt jeder zu Hause testen, ob du bei Google raufwärts bist oder nicht.
Das heisst, unter 3% bist du eben kein Roboter und deshalb wissen sie auch nicht, wie sie uns kriegen sollen.
Ob man das medizinisch auch verwenden kann.
Mit dem Internet habt ihr es wirklich und oft mit den großen Companies. Was war das mit Amazon?
Amazon Noir. Eine dunkle Geschichte, eine dunkle Story über... Na ja, es ging darum, es gab bei Amazon, gibt es jetzt auch noch, aber es wurde damals gerade so eingeführt, diese Search Inside the Book, diese Funktion. Noir to something completely different. Und die haben... Ist ja klar, dass du mit der Funktion, wenn du das missbrauchst, kannst du das ganze Buch runter sacken. Das, wie man es genau macht, ist einfach ein Programmieraufwand. Und dann hast du ein ganz tolles Buch, das natürlich nicht so sauber ist wie das Original, dafür technisch gesehen gratis. Aber darum geht es natürlich nicht, weil es ist natürlich viel, viel teurer, wenn du den ganzen Aufwand machst und so weiter. Ist ja nicht gegangen. Und es ist in dem Sinn auch ein kleinen conceptual piece, aber auf der anderen Seite war die Software zumindest so... Die Software ist ja trotzdem real zu untersaugen. Dass das natürlich jetzt auch genügend Probleme juristisch produziert hat. Und wir wollten jetzt einmal nur nach Google, wollten wir uns auch mit Amazon auseinandersetzen. Das lag irgendwie auf der Hand, oder?
Ja, weil die Trilogie, die drei grossen... Die Trilogie sind die drei grossen 90er-Jahre E-Commerce... Deshalb heisst es ja auch E-Commerz, also E-Commerce Trilogy.
Die drei grossen.
Ja, und dann war das eben so, dass wir dann sagten, okay, das ist jetzt ein... Das ist ein Projekt, das war für uns immer heikel, weil es relativ nah an dieser extremen Copy-Left-Bewegung dran ist, oder? Die dann so, es muss alles frei sein, ich denke nicht drüber nach, aber alles muss frei sein und so weiter. Ich meine, eben, ich selbst denke jetzt auch, wenn Copy läuft und so, das ist klar, aber das heisst nicht, dass ich jetzt eine politische Kämpferin dafür bin. Und deswegen ist es relativ banal, diese Sache finde ich. Jedenfalls haben wir dann am Schluss die Sache für uns einfach regeln können, indem wir die Software dann an Amazon verkauft haben. Das heisst, das war eins der wenigen Projekte von uns, mit Ausnahme von VoteAction 2, das finanziell gut ausgegangen ist für uns. Das war echt gut. Wir haben die Software dann an Amazon verkauft, wie man das halt macht, oder? Eben. Wenn man jetzt eben hackt, man was, was dann einen Fehler irgendwie aufzeigt, dann muss halt die Lösung des Fehlers gleich wieder verkaufen, damit es halt niemand weiß, wie es geht, oder?
Im Prinzip seid ihr dann Teil der Security-Szene geworden.
Richtig, du sagst es, ja.
Nein, einmal haben sie es gepatcht und dann irgendwie haben sie irgendwie Anwaltsbriefe geschickt und bei Google bringt das ja nichts, mit denen kannst du ja nicht reden, die sind ja psychotische Schizofirma, aber mit Amazon kannst du reden. Da haben wir einen Anwalt halt hingeschickt und gesagt, und dann ist der zurückgekommen und gesagt, ja, sie würden es auch kaufen, wenn es damit irgendwie dann fertig ist, das Projekt. Und für uns war das Projekt aber eh schon fertig. Das war ein Projekt auf Zeit. Nicht so wie das Google Related Self, das einfach läuft. Amazon war irgendwie abgeschlossen. 3000 Bücher geklaut, Peer to Peer verstreut über die ganze Welt, gedruckt und ausgestellt und der ganze Scheiss. Und das war dann einfach noch die Gegenreaktion, zu sagen, ok, jetzt haben wir zwei Projekte und wir haben immer das Problem, die Intention ist total anders als die Perzeption. Die Intention ist nicht eben Copyright, Copyleft, Autor oder Google an den Pranger Stellen oder sonst irgendwas, obwohl es gegen aussen zu ausschaut und so interpretiert wird. Und weil es so interpretiert wird, haben wir gesagt, jetzt machen wir die Gegenbewegung, sagen wir, we do something nice, was Nettes, was Hübsches. eBay, User-Daten, du kannst halt auf die Website, gibst deinen User-Key oder Nick ein von eBay, dann sackt es sich, also irgendein Crawler holt sich die ganzen Daten.
Also ohne dein Passwort jetzt zu haben?
Ja, ja, ja, alles öffentliche, Comments und die verkauften Sachen und der ganze Scheiss. Das geht nachher in eine Blackbox, also ich nenne es eine Blackbox, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, was da irgendwie passiert ist. Supercollider-Engine, Stefan Nussbaumer hat ein Jahr lang dran gecodet und am Schluss kommt irgendwie ein tanzbarer Techno-Track hinten raus. Und die LIA, die Generative Artist LIA, hat oben drüber noch ein paar geile Visuals gegeben und die Websites sind nackte Telletextfrauen von der Lizvlx. Und das ist so ein visuell...
So ein Fitness-Teller, so ein nettartiges Fitness-Teller.
So ein sympathisches Produkt irgendwie, wo es dann auch noch eine Edition von diesem Telletext, erstens gibt es dann noch eine 47er Edition mit auf Holzdruck. Das ist so als Holz ausgeschnitten und dann gedruckt und so. Das gibt auch kein Feedback auf das Projekt eigentlich.
Nein, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Außer, dass es am ZKM gerade gezeigt wird.
Nein, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Du warst nicht auf der einen AAS. Auf einer AAS habe ich Flyer von dem verteilt, der letzten Flyer, und jeden hat gesagt, das kenne ich, das habe ich schon gemerkt.
Es war total frustig, dieses Projekt zu bewerben, weil es jeder gekannt hat.
Zumindest hat jeder eure Trilogie zusammen.
Richtig, wir hatten unsere Trilogie zusammen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, Schluss, und haben es so Bernhards gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich hier gerade so ein schickes, dickes Buch in der Hand, das ist ganz frisch.
Genau, gerade rausgekommen. Kann man auf Amazon bestellen.
Merian Verlag, CH, da ist alles zusammengefasst. Viele Sachen, über die wir jetzt geredet haben. Und auch vieles, über das wir nicht geredet haben, weil ihr habt ja eine ganze Menge Zeug gemacht. Hübsche Fotos hier auch von diesen Papierstapeln und so. Das war jetzt nicht der Grund. Ich habe das Buch jetzt auch hier selbst erst entdeckt, als ich hier ankam. Mir ging es so ein bisschen darum, auch mal einen anderen Blick auf, wie man mit dem Internet so umgehen kann und überhaupt, was das Spannungsfeld Kunst sich manchmal so ausdenkt zu leisten, habe ich bekommen.
Danke für das Gespräch. War ganz entspannt.
Wenn wir uns hier zum Schluss noch mal dem Hörer zu. Viel Spaß soll es gemacht haben. Dieses Mal würde mich ja Kommentare noch mal ganz besonders interessieren, die mich sowieso immer interessieren. Es kommen ja Gott sei Dank auch immer so einige. Wenn ihr kluge Anmerkungen habt, dann haut sie doch rein. Wie gewohnt blog.chaosradio.ch. Oder denkt euch was anderes aus. Oder macht auch noch mal was Verrücktes. Wir brauchen eigentlich mehr Wahnsinnige. Ich finde das so mit dieser Hysterie, das ist eigentlich echt auch das Schönste. Also wenn sie wirklich alle total durchdrehen, wenn sie alle überhaupt gar nicht mehr, die sind ja dann auch alle so, die Nerven können ja einfach so wunderschön blank liegen manchmal. Also gibt es so diesen schönen Film von Pedro Almudovar, allein der Titel Frauen am Rande des Nervenzusammenbruchs. Wenn man den Film gesehen hat, dann fühlt man diesen Titel auch wirklich. Ja, weil dieser Wahn und dieses ganze, es geht alles gar nicht mehr. Und das also ausgedehnt auf das ganze Internet. Das ist dann wirklich so die Gesellschaft am Rande des Nervenzusammenbruchs. Sehr unterhaltsam. So wie dieses Gespräch. Vielen Dank, Hans und Liz.
Ja, grüße an die Zuhörer und danke auch.
Und das war's. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express. Auf Wiedersehen!